Jedes Jahr heiß erwartet unsere Sendung, in der wir mal einen Einblick in den Rasenfunk-Werkstattraum geben. Ihr habt uns Fragen gestellt, wir haben Antworten. Wer ist wir? Mein Name ist Max Jakob Ost, ich bin der Ed Genetzer auf Twitter und Frank Helmschrott ist auch hier, der Ed Helmi auf Twitter und jetzt geht's los.
Der Rasenfunk.
Da lach ich mir doch einen Arsch ab.
Echt. Alles bla bla bla ist das doch. Alles bla bla bla ist das.
Das Tribünengespräch.
Das ist ja kurios, dass ich unsere Twitter-Namen genannt hab, dabei sind wir eigentlich viel eher auf Blue Sky und Mastodon aktiv. Aber naja, hallo Frank, schön, dass du da bist.
Oder auch gar nicht mehr so wirklich, ja.
Ja, wir machen mal wieder unseren traditionellen Einblick in den Rasenfunk, der im Rahmen des Rasenfunk Royales rauskommt, aber als Tribünengespräch. Ich bin so froh, dass wir das inhaltlich glattgezogen haben. Vielleicht verwirrend ist es aber trotzdem.
Ein Spiegel der ganzen Formatveränderung seit dem letzten Jahr.
Kann man das den HörerInnen überhaupt zutrauen, Frank? Oder überfordern wir sie damit? Wenn man es jemandem zutrauen kann, dann unseren HörerInnen. Da bin ich mir allerdings auch sehr sicher. Wie geht es dir? Schön, dass du da bist.
Mir geht es gut. Vielen Dank. Ich freue mich sehr, dass ich mal wieder da sein kann. Ich hoffe, dir geht es gut. Mitten im royalen Stress. Um da gleich ein bisschen Transparenz an den Tag zu legen. Die letzte Aufnahme für den Royal, also nicht die allerletzte, aber die letzte vor dieser Sendung ist quasi wirklich eine Viertelstunde vorher zu Ende gegangen. Also seht es Max nach, wenn er schon ein kleines bisschen redemüde ist.
Ja, das ist das Interessante durch den neuen Veröffentlichungsrhythmus, dass jetzt alles zeitnäher zur Aufnahme rauskommt. Man kann quasi dabei hören, wie ich immer mehr Versprecher einbaue, weil ich einfach redemüde werde oder auch der Kopf müde wird. Aber die gute Nachricht ist etwas, was jetzt nur die Leute bei YouTube sehen können. Das ist dieser Zettel, da ist schon sehr viel pink markiert und pink bedeutet, sowohl als Podcast veröffentlicht, als auch bei YouTube. Und da sind nur noch ein paar offene Flecken. Und dann kann ich nämlich, das mache ich nach unserer Aufnahme jetzt dann, die EM-Mal planen. Das drängt nämlich auch schon so ein bisschen rein. Aber ja, mir geht es ganz gut, aber royal ist stressig. Werden wir jetzt sicherlich auch noch drauf kommen. Wir wollen heute eure Fragen beantworten, die ihr wie immer gestellt habt in Forum. Und wir haben uns überlegt, dass wir das diesmal ein bisschen strukturieren, weil es kommen immer wieder ähnliche Fragen zu ähnlichen Themengebieten. Und wir spielen jetzt einfach so ein bisschen Ping-Pong miteinander. Frank, lass uns mit dem inhaltlichen beginnen. Wir haben Fragen, viele, viele inhaltliche Fragen bekommen.
Vielleicht gehen wir als erstes mal auf die Frage nach unseren Plänen ein für dieses Jahr. Konkret jetzt für die Europameisterschaft, die vor der Tür steht.
Ja, ich leg einfach los und du hängst dich immer an meinen Monolog dran. Pläne EM. Die EM wird fett. Die EM soll ganz toll werden. Ich weiß noch nicht genau, wie die EM wird. Es wird wie immer eine Vorschau geben. Es wird auch einen Rückblick geben. Weitere Tribünengespräche werden alle Voraussichten nach nicht klappen, aber vor allem wird es im Nationalteams-Feed an jedem Tag mindestens eine Sendung geben. Da werden immer die Spiele des Tages besprochen und zu den Deutschlandspielen wird es eigene Sendung geben. Das heißt, es wird auch Tage geben, wo dann mehrere Sendungen erscheinen. Wie das im Detail aber aussieht, kann ich noch nicht sagen. Und der Grund dafür ist ein erfreulicher. Der erfreuliche Grund ist nämlich, dass ich eine Akkreditierung bekommen habe für insgesamt neun Spiele der Vorrunde. Das ist toll. Das heißt, ich kann vor Ort die Spiele verfolgen. Ich werde auch bei allen deutschen Spielen vor Ort in den Stadien sein und kann dann eben danach auch in die Mixed Zone und kann in die Pressekonferenz. Das bedeutet aber zweierlei. Zum einen bin ich dann länger beschäftigt und die Folgen zu den Deutschlandspielen werden nicht ganz so zeitnah zum Abpfiff veröffentlicht werden. Und zum anderen, das ist, glaube ich, noch der wichtigere Punkt, muss ich dafür natürlich durch Deutschland reisen, auch wenn ich mich ein bisschen auf Süddeutschland beschränkt habe. Also ich bin jetzt erstmal in München, Stuttgart und Frankfurt bei einigen Spielen akkreditiert. Und werde aber deswegen dann an diesen Tagen nicht noch das Abendspiel sehen können, wenn eben das Deutschlandspiel nicht das letzte Spiel des Tages ist. Das heißt, da müssen andere ModeratorInnen einspringen. Da wird es dann mal in diesem Jahr nicht so sein, dass ich alle Spiele des Turniers gesehen habe. Wie das genau läuft, das kläre ich jetzt dann, wenn wir hier fertig sind. Und plane das mal alles. Aber das sind unsere EM-Pläne. Es wird gut und ich freue mich auch richtig drauf, wenn man auch daran merkt, welche Entwicklung der Rasenfunk genommen hat. Ich meine, wir haben nach der WM 2014 angefangen mit dem Rasenfunk. Nein, nicht das günstigste Timing, vielleicht. Aber es ist ja schön, dass ich jetzt als akkreditierter Journalist dann vor Ort dabei sein kann. Und ich hoffe auch, dass man das der Berichterstattung anmerken will.
Da würde ich tatsächlich jetzt gleich mal direkt eine Frage in Stellvertretung, wahrscheinlich der Hörerschaft, anbringen wollen. Wie würdest du das denn ent für dich abwägen, zu sagen, wann ist mir die Sendung wichtiger oder wann ist es mir wichtiger, zeitnah eine Sendung zu haben, eine eigene Sendung zu haben versus ich kann im Stadion sein und entsprechend habe ich einen besseren Blick aufs Spiel, einen besseren Zugang, Mixed Zone etc. Was sind da deine Gedanken dazu?
Also, Stadion schlägt immer TV-Perspektive. Das heißt, inhaltlich wird jede Sendung besser, selbst wenn ich ähnliche Dinge sehe, aber ich bin mir dann ihrer sicherer, weil ich es im Stadion gesehen habe. Stadion schlägt immer die TV-Perspektive und es ist immer dann auch praktikabel, ins Stadion zu gehen für eine Sendung, wenn dafür nicht zu viel anderes ausfällt. Und das ist bei der EM so, weil da geht es dann eben um ein Spiel, das ich nicht sehen kann, oder vielleicht um ein Parallelspiel, das ich nicht gleichzeitig sehen kann, wo ich aber ja dafür sorgen kann, dass ich entweder eine Gastkonstellation habe, in der es dann mal nicht so schlimm ist, dass ich dann mal derjenige bin, der was nicht gesehen hat, oder dass vielleicht jemand anderes die Sendung moderiert, der oder die dann das Spiel gesehen hat. Bei der Bundesliga ist es ein bisschen anders. Bei der Bundesliga ist es tatsächlich ein Zeitproblem. Also ich könnte ja zu Spielen in Augsburg, Stuttgart mit ein bisschen verbiegen und in München generell könnte ich mich ja auch akkreditieren. Das mache ich allerdings sehr selten. Das mache ich in der Regel nur dann, wenn das exklusive Einzelspiele sind. Weil ansonsten verliere ich mit der Anfahrt und mit der Rückfahrt so viel Zeit, dass ich in dieser Zeit drei bis vier andere Spiele hätte sehen können. Und die Zeit habe ich am Wochenende nicht. Dadurch, dass ich so viele Spiele sehe, verzichte ich da dann. Also 15.30 Uhr wirst du mich eigentlich nie hier in München im Stadion sehen, weil da muss ich noch so viele andere Spiele sehen. Das heißt, das ist eigentlich so die Abwägung, die ich treffe. Aber während so eines Turniers, finde ich, geht das dann doch. Ich kann noch gar nichts zu sagen. Es wird was zu Olympia geben, zum Olympischen Fußballturnier der Frauen. Also ich werde mich da jetzt nur auf die Frauen konzentrieren. Das wird wahrscheinlich spielbezogen sein, aber das hängt noch komplett in der Schwebe, weil da kommen noch andere Termine mit rein. Da kann ich leider noch gar nichts Konkretes zu sagen. Es ist schon geplant, was zu machen. Aber um so transparent zu sein, da müssen wir auch mal gucken, wie wir und ich aus der EM rauskommen. Wenn ich da rauskomme wie ein nasser Sack, dann wird das sich leider auch aufs Olympische Fußballturnier auswirken.
Die beiden Fragen, inklusive der nächsten, kamen übrigens von Yuvi. Er fragt außerdem noch, ob es denn Pläne für neue Inhalte in den fünf Formaten gibt. Wie sieht es denn da aus, Max? Haben wir da schon was im Köcher?
Ich frage mich so ein bisschen, wie das gemeint ist, weil natürlich haben wir Sendungen geplant. Viele davon liegen auch auf Heide, gerade die Tribünengespräche. Ich glaube, er meint Neuerungen wirklich.
Natürlich wird es neue Inhalte geben, neue Episoden. Im Zweifel sehr häufig.
Mir reicht ehrlich gesagt die Umstellung auf fünf Feats jetzt erst mal.
Ich habe da keine Neuerungen geplant.
Das würde ja vor allem bedeuten, etwas Zusätzliches. Wie sollen wir denn das noch machen? Ich habe, es stand jetzt Mittwoch, 29. Mai, das ist jetzt meine 89. Aufzeichnung, die ich in diesem Jahr mache. Nein, meine 88. Entschuldigt. Das ist schon arg viel, muss man sagen.
Na gut, dann lasst uns zur nächsten Frage springen, und zwar die nach einem Live-Podcast. SW Nero will wissen, wann gibt es denn endlich mal einen? Die Schlusskonferenz würde sich ja wahrscheinlich nicht so gut dafür eignen.
Vor allem, weil es sie nicht mehr gibt, lieber Nero.
Genau, zum einen das und zum anderen natürlich wegen der Aktualität. Aber ein Tribünengespräch vielleicht.
Tja, sag du es mir, Frank.
Ja, wird es wahrscheinlich in irgendeiner Form geben. Wir reden da schon länger drüber. Allerdings ist es natürlich, muss man dazu sagen, an sich einfach ein riesen Projekt, so was auf die Beine zu stellen. Und bei dem Tribünengespräch muss dann terminlich alles passen, auch mit dem Gast und man muss die Location organisieren. Man muss irgendwie vieles drumrum machen. Und der Rasenfunk ist einfach schon seit langem ein sehr insgesamt sehr ausgelastetes Projekt und alles sehr, im Vergleich zu anderen Podcasts ist es ja nicht so, dass wir uns hier irgendwie zwei Wochen lang auf die nächste Folge vorbereiten, sondern vor allem Max da wöchentlich großen Termindruck hat. Und da ist so ein Projekt tatsächlich relativ schwer. Und dann fehlt wahrscheinlich auch so ein bisschen der direkte Benefit. Das ist wahrscheinlich mit dem Grund, warum wir es nicht konsequenter vorantreiben, obwohl es die Idee wirklich schon lange gibt und wir immer mal wieder darüber gesprochen haben. Aber es ist jetzt weder so, dass wir uns davon erhoffen können, viele neue Hörer zu bekommen, noch dass das alleine irgendwie eine lohnenswerte Einkommensquelle wäre. Also es hätte rein einen Community-Event-Charakter, den wir zweifelsohne natürlich genießen würden. Und auch gerne euch als regelmäßige Hörerinnen und Hörer diese Situation oder dieses Event bieten würden. Aber es ist einfach wahnsinnig viel Aufwand. Und unterm Strich haben wir alle nicht so richtig viel davon.
Und vor allem offene Frage an dich. Kennst du einen Podcast, bei dem die Live-Folgen richtig gut sind? Und vielleicht sogar einen Mehrwert noch bieten, auch für die Podcast-Konsumierenden im Vergleich zu normalen Folgen?
Also ich muss dazu sagen, ich glaube ich, also die Anzahl der Podcasts, die ich live gesehen habe, also wo ich live auch zu Gast war, das waren maximal drei, wenn überhaupt. Ich habe natürlich viele Podcast-Folgen gehört, die live aufgezeichnet wurden. Und die haben manchmal so einen netten Benefit, einen kleinen, aber eigentlich sind sie insgesamt eher immer ein bisschen anstrengend. Der Applaus zwischendurch, die schlechtere Audioqualität, das alles drumrum. Also ich würde sagen, die Podcast-Veröffentlichung ist eher ein Downgrade am Ende im Vergleich zu der normalen Folge. Und wenn wir jetzt zum Beispiel aufs Tribünengespräch gucken, wenn man das als Vorschlag nimmt, eine Interviewfolge, kann man sich sicherlich gut vorstellen. Aber ich wüsste nicht, unter welchen Umständen diese Live-Folge besser wäre als eine aufgezeichnete.
Genau, so sehe ich es nämlich auch. Ich finde, es gibt ganz, ganz wenige Live-Podcasts, die wirklich gut funktionieren. Ansonsten ist es einfach nur der Community-Effekt, der natürlich schön ist. Das habe ich auch auf meiner Lesereise gemerkt, dass es halt schön ist, die HörerInnen mal zu treffen. Und das macht auch Spaß. Aber das Produkt wird dadurch um keinen Deut besser. Ich kann mich wirklich an keinen einzigen Podcast erinnern. Es gibt so ein paar, die es trotz Live-Situationen schaffen, eine gute, tiefgehende Sendung zu machen. Also Logbuch Netzpolitik hat die Folge mit Alexander Hessenthaler, also dem Whistleblower mit dem Ibiza-Video. Die haben sie auf einem Chaos-Camp gemacht, ich glaube nicht auf einem Kongress. Das war zum Beispiel eine gute Sendung, obwohl sie live war, aber weil die sich trotzdem drei Stunden mit ihm hingesetzt haben. Und weil das auch ein entsprechendes Publikum war, was jetzt auch gar nicht erwartet hat, einbezogen zu werden. Aber ansonsten fallen mir da sehr wenige Vorschläge ein. Und da würde mich jetzt die Rückfrage, die ich dann an die HörerInnen stellen würde, wäre, wollt ihr wirklich einen Live-Podcast oder wollt ihr nicht einfach nur uns kennenlernen? Weil das wäre ja beides für mich okay, nur für das eine brauchen wir nicht, noch vorher irgendwie einen Gast rankann und irgendwie zu versuchen, in dann 90 Minuten Inhalt reinzupacken. Das andere ist ein bisschen schneller erreicht. Könnte er ja mal schreiben.
Können wir, glaube ich, so stehen lassen. Antworten im Forum natürlich immer möglich. Der Thread heißt Rasenfunk Fragen und Antworten, der zu dieser Sendung passt. Da kann es gerne noch weiter diskutiert werden. Wir springen einfach zur nächsten Frage, beziehungsweise in dem Fall ein kleines bisschen kritisches Feedback von Dyrion. Der findet nämlich das neue Intro nicht so gut und damit meint er natürlich diesen Coldopener, den du am Anfang vor dem musikalischen Intro einsprichst und danach noch mal die Vorstellung der Gäste. Er nennt es jetzt ausführliche Vorstellungen. Ich glaube aber fast, dass das gar nicht wirklich so ist, weil du ja eigentlich erstmal nur den Gast vorstellst, den du direkt ansprichst.
Also eigentlich ist der ganze Beginn der Folgen schneller geworden durch den Coldopener. Und deswegen wollten wir ihn beide ja auch mal ausprobieren, weil es eben nicht mehr ist... Also, dass ich mich vorstelle, das musste mich ja erst wieder irgendwann ein Hörer dran erinnern, der geschrieben hat, ey, wer bist du überhaupt? Ich weiß immer gar nicht, wer spricht. Und ich so, ach ja, stimmt, ich stelle mich ja gar nicht mehr vor im Coldopener. Deswegen mache ich das jetzt manchmal. Oft lasse ich es dann auch wieder weg, weil irgendwie finde ich es auch albern. Kann man ja in den Shownotes nachlesen. Aber eigentlich beginnen die Folgen jetzt schneller. Die Intros sind auch kürzer geworden. Das fand ich interessant, dass das eigentlich niemand thematisiert hat. Ich, das war Teil unserer Klausurtagung, ich weiß gar nicht welcher, dass wir beschlossen haben, diesen Aktualitätsanspruch, den ich hatte, dass ich bei den Spieltags-Sendungen immer auch ein Zitat eines Otunggebers vom Spieltag genommen habe und am liebsten von demjenigen, der auch im Schwerpunkt vorkommt. Das haben wir komplett über Bord geworfen. Das sind zeitlose Intros und deswegen konnte ich da aber auch kürzere Schnipsel verwenden, die halt oft schwieriger zu finden sind. Das heißt, alles ist jetzt schneller geworden. Ich versuche eigentlich auch häufig direkt mit was Inhaltlichen zu starten. Deswegen, ich kann verstehen, wenn es Leute irritiert, dass da direkt losgeplappert wird. Früher, aber wir hatten ähnliche Rückmeldungen, als wir noch das Anschalten des Radios hatten. Das ist ja so ein altes Tastenradio, deswegen klackt es ja so in unserem Intro. Da gab es doch auch mal die Beschwerde, dass das viel zu laut ist. Und dann habe ich es ein paar Dezibel leiser gemacht. Da hat sich nie wieder jemand gemeldet. Vielleicht war es dann wirklich die paar Dezibel leiser. Aber ich kann verstehen, dass es irritierend ist. Aber ich habe den Eindruck, es tut den Sendungen gut, weil wir schneller zum Punkt kommen und auch dadurch, dass ich den ganzen Hausmeister-Teil verschoben habe. Das tut mir manchmal noch so ein bisschen leid, weil ich das Gefühl habe, dass die Dinge nicht so gut ankommen bei den Menschen, weil die vielleicht diese Kapitelmarke überspringen oder gar nicht so weit hören. Das ist manchmal noch ein Problem. Aber ansonsten, finde ich, kommen wir viel schneller in die Folgen rein.
Er hat ja die Vermutung geäußert, dass es um die bessere Sichtbarmachung in den sozialen Medien bzw. in YouTube geht. Vielleicht ein kleiner Nebeneffekt davon oder vielleicht ein Gedanke, der aus dieser Ecke angestoßen wurde, weil natürlich gerade bei YouTube gibt es ja die Statistiken über die Verlaufkurven, welche Teile eines Videos wie gesehen werden von Hörern. Aber grundsätzlich ging es uns eigentlich schon von uns aus darum, am Anfang schneller zu den Inhalten zu kommen. Weil mit dem alten Format erst musikalisches Intro, langes Intro mit viel Zitat, Audio, dann lange Vorstellungen, dann noch mal Housekeeping. Oft hat es irgendwie vier, fünf Minuten gedauert, bis überhaupt mal inhaltlich losging bei der Sendung. Und die ganzen Formatänderungen auch des letzten Jahres standen ja ein bisschen unter dem Motto, vor allem die damalige Schlusskonferenz, also jetzt die Bundesliga-Männer-Analyse-Sendung, zugänglicher zu machen. Jetzt ist es ein bisschen kürzer durch die Auslagerung des Schwerpunkts. Der Anfang ist ein bisschen schneller. Also es ist eigentlich so ein durchgängiger Faden, der sich da durchzieht und das ist auch die Introänderung.
Und es baut auch auf der Entscheidung auf, jetzt bei festen Intros zu bleiben, denn ansonsten wüsstest du nicht, wo du bist. Weil du hörst jetzt im Intro Mario Basler, Ailton oder sonst wem sprechen. Worum geht es hier eigentlich? Vor allem, wenn ich dann öfter mal, die wiederholen sich ja dann auch die Intros, weil ich es nicht geschafft habe, genügend neue zu schneiden. Das war einfach immer nicht möglich. Auch deshalb quasi erste Orientierung, worüber wird hier eigentlich gesprochen. Wer spricht hier überhaupt, dann das Intro, was, wenn man ehrlich ist, inzwischen nicht mehr so viel Bezug hat. Und das tut mir eigentlich am allermeisten weh, unser Audodesign ist jetzt zerschossen. Das Audodesign war ja vorher Radio anschalten, Sender suchen, Rasenfunk finden, Sendung geht los, Outro startet, Ende des Programms, es geht über in weißes Rauschen, das Radio wird abgeschaltet. So war ja bisher unser Sounddesign. Dass sich das aufbrechen musste, fand ich eigentlich am allerschlimmsten von allem. Aber es war es trotzdem wert.
Ja, ich fände auch. Also ich bin sehr zufrieden damit, wie es jetzt ist und das war tatsächlich bisher auch, glaube ich, das erste kritische Feedback, dass wir dazu gehört haben, oder?
Ja, genau. Ansonsten eigentlich nur positive Rückmeldungen. Auch von den Gästen habe ich den Eindruck. Weil ich auch die Gästevorstellung, die ist zwar manchmal fast ein bisschen zu kurz, aber alle, die es interessiert, die gucken in die Shownotes.
Dann steht in der Regel ein Twitter-Profil drin und sonst irgendwas. Also man kommt leicht an die Info. Dann kommt ein nächster Punkt. Da steht jetzt Ligatur bei Gästen beliebt. Das haben wir uns notiert als Stichpunkt. Aber das war tatsächlich eine Diskussion in dem zugehörigen Sendungsthread. Ein bisschen ausgelöst von Eric mit einer Frage dazu. Und dann gab es eine kleine Diskussion zu den Inhalten. Vielleicht willst du einfach mal so ein bisschen auf den Komplex eingehen.
Die Ligatur. Also erstmal geht es hier jetzt um die Ligatur Europa. Es kam so generell die Frage, wie entwickeln sich Ligatur, zweite Liga, Ligatur, Europa. Beide entwickeln sich so. Geht so. Also die Trennung, also dass wir den Ligaturfeed auf den Kern wieder reduziert haben, das ist gut. Definitiv, dass jetzt quasi die Tribünengesprächartigen Sendungen daraus sind, dass wir die Frauen in der eigenen Feed gepackt haben. Das ist alles wunderbar.
Der ehemalige Kurzpass, weiß ich noch. Jemand, der erinnert.
Der ehemalige Kurzpass.
Die Alten werden es wissen.
Ich habe gerade kurz überlegt. Ich war mir gerade wirklich nicht mehr genau sicher. Ich wusste noch, es war blau. Aber von den Download-Zahlen her, also gut, ich habe jetzt ehrlicherweise auch nicht mehr ganz genau jetzt reingeguckt, jetzt in den letzten Wochen hatte es zu viel zu tun. Aber das hat leider dann noch nicht so angezogen. Und dann haben wir ja quasi zwei Formate entwickelt. Und das eine ist die Zweitliga-Tour, bei der wir jetzt ein festes inhaltliches Korsett gefunden haben, was, wie ich finde, sehr gut funktioniert. Kurzer Blick auf die Liga, in der Regel drei Gäste. Und mit diesen drei Gästen 15 bis 20 Minuten zum jeweiligen Verein. Sagen wir realistisch, es sind immer 20 Minuten. Das heißt, du landest bei einer Stunde 15, Stunde 20. Und hast dann in der Regel alle zwei Wochen einen Überblick, einen tieferen Einblick, ein bisschen tieferen Einblick bei den beiden, bei den drei Vereinen. Und einen kurzen Blick über die Liga. Das funktioniert super. Ist allerdings vom Orga-Aufwand her logischerweise schon ein Brett. Weil du musst immer diese drei Leute finden. Du musst dir überlegen, welche Vereine wollen wir jetzt mal wieder mit drin haben. Und du musst dann gemeinsam Termin finden für alle. Und weil das nicht möglich ist, auch noch für die europäische Ligatur zu machen, haben wir da ein anderes Format gewählt, nämlich immer derselbe Aufnahmezeitpunkt, immer derselbe Pool an Gästen. Und im Grunde ist es dann eine Nachricht, die ich schreibe, Leute, nächste Woche ist wieder Aufnahme. Wer hat Zeit? Wer ist wieder dran? Und dann melden sich alle bis auf die Liga. Die hatten sehr viel zu tun dieses Jahr, leider. Und so kommen wir quasi zu dieser Aufteilung. Und das ist aber etwas, was den Gästen sehr gut gefällt. Weil auch wenn manche dann länger nicht mit dabei sind, hat es was Verlässliches. Und was sehr schön ist, ist, dass es fast schon eine Routine geworden ist. Also manchmal kriege ich die Themen irgendwie 30 Sekunden bevor wir aufzeichnen. Und ich habe aber dann schon den Record-Button gedrückt, weil wir sind so im Flow, dass ich auch weiß, ich muss da jetzt nicht noch vorher sagen, ich freue mich, wenn ihr euch auch miteinander unterhaltet. Und das hier ist übrigens der Mute-Button. Und achtet darauf, dass ihr in der Kamera ordentlich zu sehen seid. Okay, das muss ich doch noch manchmal sagen. Grüße an der Stelle, ich sage nicht an wen. Aber das ist eigentlich etwas sehr Gutes. Und das stellt auch meine Meinung nach. Und darüber wurde aber hier im Forum diskutiert. Das fand ich interessant. Aber wir zwei waren eigentlich immer Fan davon, welche Gesprächsatmosphäre das herstellt. Und das ist eigentlich auch die Sendung, obwohl es ein festeres Korsett ist, hat es die Sendung befreit, weil wir manchmal Abzweigungen nehmen, die nicht geplant sind. Und dann erzählt uns alles einmal Uli Hebel, wie er im Monaco im Supermarkt eingekauft hat. Und das ist aber die Anekdote, an die ich mich noch eher erinnere, als an viele andere Anekdoten. Also es ist so eine Art Laberformat von uns geworden, mit einer Besetzung, die man kennt. Und nach allem, was ich gehört habe, funktioniert es für die Gäste genauso gut wie für uns. Und mich entlastet es unheimlich, da nicht immer nochmal Leute suchen zu müssen.
Es ist ja lustig, dass die Idee oder den Gedanken, das eventuell so zu machen, auch schon vor zehn Jahren gab. Ganz am Anfang das Rasenfunk. Da haben wir auch schon mal darüber gesprochen, ob das eine Option für die Schlusskonferenz damals sein könnte, dass man einfach einen festen Pool an Gästen aufbaut, die man kennt. Das war ja auch noch in der Zeit, als wir ganz Anfang über Video auch schon nachdachten, wo man dann natürlich Gäste gebraucht hätte, die entsprechende Anbindung, Ausrüstung haben etc. Aber ja, interessant, dass wir da wieder gelandet sind.
Ich meine, letztlich ist es im bundesligen Bereich so. Es ist ja ein relativ fester Pool und ich mag das auch sehr, dass es wieder erkennbare Stimmen sind. Was wir halt natürlich sofort übern... Also eigentlich war das Ursprungskonzept des Rasenfunk vor ja jetzt wirklich fast zehn Jahren. Wir werden jetzt ja dann zehn im August. War ja fester Pool an Gästen, die durchrotieren und wir wechseln uns in der Moderation ab. Alle zwei Wochen. Wir haben noch eine weitere Frage bekommen, aber ich glaube, die muss auch ich beantworten, weil der Ball bei mir läge, ob noch andere liegen geplant sind. Nein. Nein. Und ich sage es euch so, wie ich es auch in all den letzten solchen Sendungen hier immer gesagt habe. Es hat 0,0 damit zu tun, dass ich mich nicht für andere Ligen interessieren würde. Im Gegenteil. Es gab ja zum Beispiel auch mal eine Folge zu Was ist los bei Ajax Amsterdam? Aber wenn ich jetzt noch anfange, fange Eredivisie und Österreichische Bundesliga und Super League zu machen, dann kommen die ersten, die zurecht fragen, was ist denn mit südamerikanischen Fußball? Und dann kommen die nächsten und sagen, das bekomme ich ja regelmäßig. Wann machst du denn mal was zur dritten Liga? Irgendwo muss die Grenze gezogen werden. Es hat nichts damit zu tun, dass wir uns für irgendetwas nicht interessieren würden. Im Gegenteil, wir hätten auch Lust, die ganze Zeit über alles zu reden, aber irgendwo muss die Grenze gezogen werden. Deswegen, diese fünf Top-Ligen stehen im Fokus. Vielleicht gibt es hin und wieder mal Ausnahmen, aber ich bekomme diese Frage so oft, dass ich auch sehr oft aufpassen muss, da nicht so schnippisch drauf zu reagieren, weil das oft kommt, wenn ich gerade von einer Aufzeichnung in die nächste hetze und mir denke, ja wann?
Ich glaube, das Problem ist natürlich immer ein bisschen, diese Frage kommt ja ganz selten von ganz eingefleischten Hörern, die auch diese Q&A-Sendungen schon seit fünf Jahren hören, die uns super kennen, die die Probleme kennen, die wir haben, die im Grunde alles wissen rund um den Rasenfunk. Diese Fragen kommen ja eigentlich eher von vielleicht neueren Hörern oder von jemandem, der vorbeikommt und sich denkt, Mensch, ist ja alles ganz cool, aber eigentlich würde mich ja jetzt Liga X interessieren und dann fragt man halt. Und das ist ja auch völlig legitim, danach zu fragen. Aber das Problem, das man natürlich als Außenstehender hat, ist, dass man die Komplexität nicht erkennt, die dahintersteckt. Einerseits das selber gucken, das genau auskennen, das Gäste finden, das regelmäßige Gäste finden und dann die Aufnahme einplanen. Also die Aufnahme an sich, so einer Sendung, ist da im Vergleich noch das einfachste wahrscheinlich. Aber der ganze Komplex, der sich darum strickt, um so ein vielleicht neues Format, ist viel zu groß und absolut unrealistisch, dass da in nächster Zeit irgendwas passiert.
Und man muss noch einen weiteren Aspekt mit reinbringen. Diejenigen, die das fragen, kennen sich ja in der Regel bei dem Thema aus, dass sie gerne einen Rasenfunk hätten. Und ihr werdet die allerersten, die enttäuscht werden, wie in Anführungszeichen oberflächlich nur gesprochen werden würde, über die dritte Liga oder über eben die Liga eurer Wahl. Weil eben auch nur eine gewisse Tiefe, Tiefe ist nur mit Zeit leistbar. Für Zeit braucht es ein Zeitkontingent. Und für Tiefe braucht es aber auch noch eine inhaltliche Vorkenntnis. Also in der Ligatur, so wie sie jetzt ist, kann ich als Moderator, könnte ich auch so drüber hudeln, ohne was zu wissen. Ich weiß natürlich immer ein bisschen mehr, weil ich schon versuche, auf dem Stand zu bleiben, aber nie so viel wie die ExpertInnen. Aber das wird schwer da dann ins Detail reinzugehen, weil da muss man sich auch an alles erinnern, was in den vergangenen Sendungen dran war. Und da scheitert es bei mir bei so vielen Sendungen. Und der zweite Aspekt ist noch, also früher habe ich eine Sendung gemacht am Tag, und dann war der Tag gelaufen, einfach weil die Konzentrationsfähigkeit so hoch ist, weil die Postproduktion so lange dauert, weil es auch einfach anstrengend ist, so eine Sendung aufzunehmen. Inzwischen bin ich ja schon so weit, dass ich manchmal drei Sendungen am Tag mache, aber das ist wirklich das absolute, also das ist eigentlich auch nicht gut, eigentlich sind drei Sendungen zu viel, zwei Sendungen sind schon krass. Wenn ich morgens die Männer-Bundesliga mache und abends die Frauen-Bundesliga, eigentlich ist das schon zu viel streng genommen. Aber wir machen es halt trotzdem, weil wir es machen wollen und weil es ja auch immer Spaß macht und weil ich es ja auch ganz okay hinkriege dann doch, dank der Gäste, das liegt nur an den Gästen, die könnten mich da auch richtig hängen lassen, wenn ich mal so einen schlechten Moment habe. Aber da müssen wir auch realistisch bleiben, das ist nicht leistbar, solange das hier so ein Zwei-Mann-Betrieb ist. Und inhaltlich ist es ja ein 1,1 Mann-Betrieb, weil du ja inhaltlich mich immer bremst und Feedback gibst usw. Aber ich ja dann doch viele Sendungen trage.
Ja, zu dem Teilaspekt Frauenfußball kommen wir auch gleich noch. Dann gehen wir mal zur nächsten Frage. Es geht ums Tribünengespräch. war zu erwarten. Die Frage kam, ich weiß jetzt kann ich nicht mehr von wem, das haben wir nicht notiert.
Ich glaube auch vom Hamas.
War die auch vom Hamas nach einem Interview- Tribünengespräch? Speziell die Frage nach einem Klopp-Tribünengespräch kam von Hamas Melna. Ich glaube, die Interview-Tribünengespräch-Frage kam von jemand anderem. Aber egal. Also es geht darum, ob denn Interview-Tribünengespräche mal wieder geplant sind, weil die bisherigen ja durchaus zu den besten gehören, nach Meinung des Fragestellenden.
Selbe Antwort wie die letzten Jahre. Ja, es ist geplant, aber ich komme nicht dazu. Zum Teil ist es auch schon sehr konkret geplant gewesen, aber es passt einfach leider nicht mehr in die Wochen rein, weil die Wochen jetzt so voll sind. Auch durch die Formatumstellung. Es sind jetzt so viele Sendungen, dass jetzt noch mehr Tage von Sendungen blockiert sind. Also in der Regel sind es ja am Montag zwei, Dienstag halte ich, versuche ich mir irgendwie freizuhalten, schafft schon, klappt schon oft nicht. Mittwoch definitiv eine, Donnerstag meistens eine und dann startet ja schon wieder das Bundesliga-Wochenende. Also ja, wäre schön. Zu so was wie Jürgen Klopp, möchte ich sagen, gerade so die naheliegenden Themen, die machen doch oft andere Podcasts. Ich hätte jetzt auch kein Christian-Streich-Tribünengespräch gemacht, wenn wir da nicht in Kooperation mit einem Spotcast hätten machen können. Weil ich mir denke, dazu braucht es doch eigentlich den Rasenfunk nicht, weil es gibt doch genügend. Also die Enfeedrap hat jetzt viel zu Jürgen Klopp gemacht. Es gibt internationale Podcasts. Ganz bestimmt wird es auch deutsche Produktionen bald geben. Wahrscheinlich ist Keshar Berusch jetzt gerade wahrscheinlich schon im Auto, um rüberzufahren. ich finde, da braucht es dann den Rasenfunk auch nicht unbedingt. Und ich freue mich, dass... Ja, ich meine klar, wahrscheinlich schon irgendwas, weil die Art und Weise, wie wir über Kai Bernstein sprechen, ist eine andere, als andere über Kai Bernstein gesprochen haben. Aber dennoch ist es ein Hinterherlaufen eines Themas, bei dem du eigentlich aber dann doch nur verlieren kannst. Weil, also wenn wir jetzt ein Jürgen Klopp-Tribünengespräch gemacht hätten, es wundert mich, dass es noch nicht so viel gibt, wie ich gedacht hätte, jetzt zu seinem Abschied. Ich hätte das anders angeschätzt, ich dachte es gibt Dokus und was weiß ich alles, aber letztlich geht dann der Rasenfunk da auch unter. Es kriegt dann keine Sichtbarkeit. Deswegen, also gerade bei so offensichtlichen Themen, finde ich, muss es nicht immer der Rasenfunk machen. Hier, WM 2014 machen. Gibt es jetzt zwei Podcasts, eine Fernseh-Doku und so weiter? Ich habe natürlich auch drüber nachgedacht, da was zu machen und dachte mir dann ne, da machen jetzt ja alle anderen so. Also dann mache ich lieber im 13. Jahr nach der WM 2014 was dazu.
Ja, die nächste Frage. Sind denn weitere Formatänderungen geplant? Ne, ich glaube nur ist es erstmal gut. Also es war tatsächlich schon viel. Änderungen, die kompletten Änderungen auf die 5 Feats und so, da war schon einiges drin. Ich glaube die nächsten Sachen werden eher ein bisschen Feinjustagen sein.
Ja, es gibt natürlich ein Thema, aber das will ich jetzt hier nicht öffentlich rausposaunen. Aber wir beide wissen, welches Thema. Es gibt eine inhaltliche Unschärfe, gibt's noch innerhalb unserer Feed-Struktur. Die HörerInnen werden es wahrscheinlich auch erahnen können. Aber da kann man ja endlich mal den Staffelstab an dich weiterleiten. Obwohl wir hier im Thema Inhaltliches sind. Aber du kannst ja, wenn du magst, noch mal zumindest kurz skizzieren, was das auf technischer Seite allein bedeutet hat, dass wir von 3 auf 5 Feeds umgestellt haben.
Ja, es war ein ziemlicher Aufwand, weil wir uns natürlich aus heutiger Sicht vielleicht auch ein bisschen, müsste man sagen, ein bisschen leichtsinnig irgendwann mal dazu entschieden haben, von Standardsoftware abzuweichen und in Sachen Website alles selber zu machen. Weil wir ein bisschen zur Detailverliebtheit neigen und ich glaube, das ging damals vor allem mit dem Umstieg zu Podigy einher. Da gab es keine gute fertige Lösung. Also mussten wir was eigenes machen. Das hat dann dazu geführt, dass schon die erste Version aufwendig war und die neue Version der Website, die jetzt glaube ich, ich weiß gar nicht mehr, wann sind wir denn mit der online gegangen?
Für irgendeinem Turnier.
Das bringt es zeitlich nicht mehr auf die Reihe. Kann sein, 21 könnte hinkommen. Die mussten wir jetzt im Grunde wieder relativ massiv verändern für die Umstellung auf die 5 Feet. Das hatte natürlich optisch vom Design her ein paar Änderungen, weil da auf einmal statt vorher 3 jetzt 5 Feet dargestellt werden mussten. Wie das dann so ist, dann arbeiten wir natürlich mit einem Haufen darunter liegender Tools, die dann auch über die Jahre sich verändert haben. Dann haben wir das gleich genutzt, um einen großen Update-Schlag zu machen. Also es war relativ aufwändig. Wenn wir jetzt weitere, wie du es gerade genannt, unschärfen, korrigieren, würde das auch weitere Änderungen dahin wieder nach sich ziehen.
Ja, aber man muss eben nochmal betonen, alles, was ihr eben auf rasenfunk.de seht, ist eben von Frank mit einem Helferlein programmiert. Du hast dir das alles ausgedacht. Seins hat es alles der Tobi, den ihr ja auch kennt, der auch die Farben und so weiter ausgewählt hat. Das ist auch alles ganz wunderbar. Es macht uns beiden auch Spaß, solche Dinge zu tun. Aber das ist ein irrer Aufwand, das zum Laufen zu bekommen. Und wenn dann mal Kleinigkeiten nicht funktionieren, wie wir es jetzt jüngst erst vor ein paar Tagen hatten, dann musst du springen und musst das irgendwie fixen. Das ist schon nicht zu unterschätzen. Und der große Unterschied, den wir da einfach zu anderen Podcasts haben für all die Technik-Line da draußen, ist, dass wir eben mehrere Feeds gleichzeitig bedienen unter dem Dach des Rasenfunks. Denn in der Regel sind die automatisierten Podcast-Webseiten auf einen Feed hin konzipiert. Und das war quasi die große Frage, wie machen wir das? Das ist das sogenannte Holgi-Problem. Alle, die ein bisschen in der Podcast-Szene drin sind, die wissen genau, was damit gemeint ist. Und da gab es verschiedene technische Lösungen. Und wir haben uns aber dafür entschieden, dass wir uns selbst was bauen, also dass du uns etwas baust. Und deswegen, also bevor ich jetzt zu dir komme und sage, Frank, ich hätte gern den sechsten Feed, also da dreh ich mich aber selber vorher erst mal 35 Mal im Kreis, bevor ich mich das traue. Weil da sehe ich es dann schon in deinen Augen zerbrechen.
Die nächste Rasenfunkklausur sollte ich vielleicht mit Schutzbekleidung betreten.
Mir reichen die fünf.
Okay, also um es zusammenzufassen, keine großen Formatänderungen geplant. Im Kleinen werden wir immer justieren, aber so soll es ja auch sein. Dann der letzte inhaltliche Punkt, Max. Wie sieht es denn so mit dem Frauenfußball aus? Die Belle hat danach gefragt, wollte wissen, ob es auch beim Rasenfunk ein, wie hat sie es formuliert, ich glaube Draufzahlgeschäft oder so ähnlich ist. Und naja, einfach wie der aktuelle Stand ist, wie sich die Zahlen entwickeln und so weiter.
Also der Stand ist gut. Draufzahlgeschäft gibt es bei uns ja nicht, weil es ist ja nicht so, dass wir irgendwie jetzt messen könnten, wer finanziert uns, weil wir Frauenfußball machen und wer nicht. Es gibt zwar immer wieder Leute, die das in die Verwendungszwecke reinschreiben. Das ploppt dann mal so punktuell auf, aber da haben wir beide keine Statistik für.
Genau.
Die Downloads entwickeln sich gut, glaube ich. Ich bin ja immer nicht so... Ich versuche mich unabhängig von Reichweiten Gedanken zu machen, weil ja ganz viel im Sportjournalismus daran krank, dass man nur auf Reichweiten guckt. Was ich aber... Die Reichweiten, die ich immer sehe, sind die YouTube-Videos, was da eben immer angezeigt wird. Und da jetzt zum Beispiel haben wir jetzt zweimal in Folge deutlich über 1000 Views gehabt. Und das war eben immer so die Grenze, über die die Sendungen zur Bundesliga der Frauen selten drüber gehüpft sind. Was aber nicht nur an den Sendungen liegt, sondern auch am ungünstigen Veröffentlichungszeitpunkt. Also das sagt jetzt nicht nur was aus über... Interessiert keinen, sondern es hat auch damit zu tun, dass die in der Regel in der Nacht auf Dienstag erscheinen, wenn vorher eine oder sogar zwei Sendungen erschienen sind. Und danach kommt meistens noch eine weitere Sendung dann am Mittwoch. Das ist auch einfach ein schlechter Spot.
Sie hat es übrigens Investitionsprojekt genannt. Ich hab noch mal nachgelesen. Also nicht Draufzahlgeschäft. Das war eine sehr saloppe von mir eingeworfene Formulierung.
Ja, das finde ich natürlich schön, weil das ist ja das, was dem Fußball der Frauen fehlt, nämlich Investitionen. Und als solches würde ich schon bezeichnen, weil wir einfach sehr viel Energie und Zeit da rein investieren und auch sehr viel Liebe. Ich hoffe, das hört man den Sendung auch an. Und wir haben einen ganz schönen Gästepool, wie ich finde, in dem man rotieren kann. Und sie hat ja auch die Frage gestellt nach den Ex- oder aktuellen Profi-Spielerinnen, die mit dabei sind. Das ist halt tatsächlich das, was diesen ganzen Bereich noch mal so ein Sahnehäubchen aufsetzt, dass das möglich ist. Und dass wir da auch rein theoretisch noch viel mehr machen könnten, wenn irgendwie die Zeit dafür da wäre. Ich meine, ich bin froh, dass es da Alternativen gibt. Nina macht ja mit der 45 fast jede Woche ein tolles Interview. Raus aus dem Abseits hört man immer wieder interessante Gespräche. Eben direkt mit Spielerinnen, mit Trainerinnen. Und das finde ich eben total interessant, dass das geht. Und das wäre natürlich eigentlich schön, wenn da der Rasenfunk noch eine größere Rolle spielen könnte. Aber das scheitert halt wie immer am Faktor Zeit. Aber ich finde, es entwickelt sich super und ich bekomme vor allem wirklich sehr regelmäßig die Rückmeldung von Menschen, dass sie wegen des Rasenfunks sich jetzt besser auskennen. Und weil sie sich ein bisschen besser auskennen, sie sich auf einmal für die Ergebnisse interessieren. Und weil sie sich für die Ergebnisse interessieren, wollen sie dann auch hören, wie das Spiel gelaufen ist und hören dann die Folge doch, die sie vielleicht im ersten Schritt einfach nur angehört haben, weil sie vom Rasenfunk gekommen ist. Also das scheint wirklich bei vielen zu passieren. Und das merkt man auch den Kommentaren an, meiner Meinung nach. Das sind nicht mehr immer dieselben fünf Verdächtigen, die unter den Folgen kommentieren, sowohl bei YouTube als auch im Forum, sondern da kommen immer wieder neue Leute rein. Und ich bekomme auch manchmal Rückmeldungen von Menschen, die sagen, nur wegen des Rasenfunks wissen sie jetzt überhaupt Bescheid, sowohl was Nationalteam der Frauen angeht, als auch was die Bundesliga der Frauen angeht. Also ich würde sagen, es geht gerade voll auf, es macht richtig Spaß. Und es tut manchmal ein bisschen weh, dass wir die Möglichkeiten, die wir da haben, gar nicht voll ausschöpfen können, weil es halt leider nicht geht.
Okay, dann würde ich sagen, an dieser Stelle schließen wir diesen Themenkomplex Inhalt ab und wenden uns Struktur und Organisation zu. So haben wir es hier mal genannt. Und zwar geht es da erst im ersten Punkt auch nochmal ein bisschen um das, was wir schon so ein bisschen angeschnitten haben, nämlich die Umstrukturierung der Formate. Wie sind wir denn zufrieden mit den neuen Formaten auch und vor allem bezüglich der Einzelsendungen? Und ich nehme an, da geht es jetzt sowohl um die Analyse bzw. Schwerpunkt bei ehemaliger Schlusskonferenz bei der Bundesliga Männer, aber auch beim Royale, würde ich sagen.
Also da finde ich, ist ja deine Perspektive eigentlich die interessantere fast. Du nimmst es ja als hörenderbar. Wie findest du es denn?
Ich finde es super. Ich finde es super sortiert, super klar. Ich nehme es natürlich als hörenderbar, obwohl ich natürlich Teil des Entscheidungsprozesses war. Aber ich würde sagen, aus der hörenden Sicht, das geht genau auf, was wir damit wollten. Wir wollten die ehemalige Schlusskonferenz besser zugänglich machen. Die Analysesendung ist dadurch ein bisschen kürzer. Der Schwerpunkt ist separiert, wo wir immer gesagt haben, das macht es besser auch für YouTube, weil wir dann einen klaren Themenfokus haben, nämlich entweder der Spieltag oder die bisherige Saisonbilanz des jeweiligen Vereins. Beim Royal war der Anlass ein bisschen anderer, weil wir gesagt haben, organisatorisch muss sich da auch ein bisschen was für dich verändern. Da kannst du ja dann gleich nochmal was dazu sagen, wie sich in beiden Fällen das für dich verändert hat, was die Produktion angeht. Aber ich glaube, und das, was ich gelesen habe, sowohl zum Royal als auch im Laufe der Saison zu der Aufsplittung, kommt in der Hörerschaft eigentlich fast durchweg gut an.
Würde ich auch sagen. Im Grunde wussten wir das ja auch beide. Schon all die letzten Jahre, wo wir immer mal wieder darüber diskutiert haben, müsste man das nicht eigentlich machen. Weil eben diese dreieinhalb Stunden Sendungen sehr sperrig waren. Und weil, obwohl wir uns sehr viel Mühe geben, nicht nur Kapitelmarken einzubauen, sondern sie auch auf der Homepage prominent zu platzieren und so weiter, es trotzdem einen nennenswerten Anteil an Menschen gibt, die Kapitelmarken nicht nutzen. Auch aus welchen Gründen auch immer. Und dann finden die die Schwerpunkte nicht. Und die Schwerpunkte gehen dann auch unter. Also wir hatten ja ganz oft tolle Gespräche, die man auch gut noch drei Monate später hätte hören können. Aber wer erinnert sich denn dann noch, in welcher Sendung das drin war? Ich habe das immer versucht, durch die Wortspiele anzudeuten, um welchen Verein es geht.
Und da kommt, finde ich, noch ein ganz wichtiger Aspekt dazu, den man fast vergisst, nämlich auch bei der Gästeauswahl. Ohne dass irgendein Gast natürlich jetzt für irgendwas schlecht wäre, um Gottes Willen. Aber man hat vielleicht den Gast, den man so gerne für den Schwerpunkt Eintracht Frankfurt einladen würde und weiß aber, der hat schon angekündigt, er verfolgt die restliche Bundesliga vielleicht nicht mit dem Detail gerade, dass er sich in einer Schlusskonferenz, in einer Analysesendung wohlfühlen würde und viel beitragen kann. Und jetzt haben wir eben die Möglichkeit, beides zu machen.
Das ist ein ganz wichtiger Punkt. Das war nämlich eine sehr, sehr häufige Rückmeldung von Gästen, weiblich und männlich, dass sie gesagt haben, ich würde gerne mitmachen, aber ich kann nicht die anderen Spiele verfolgen. Und es ist ja eigentlich auch total naheliegend, gerade JournalistInnen, die einen Fokus auf einen Verein haben, die sind da richtig tief drin, die müssen aber auch das ganze Wochenende für und rund um diesen Verein arbeiten. Wie sollen die irgendwie noch nebenher andere Spiele verfolgen? Also das hat definitiv die Gästewahl erleichtert. Es ist aber natürlich, und deswegen haben wir ja diesen Schritt zu lange rausgezögert, es ist vom Aufwand her aber halt schon eine andere Nummer. Also es sind halt zwei Sendungen statt einer. Die Sendungen werden insgesamt auch länger. Das ist gerade auch wunderbar am Royal zu sehen, wo ich in den gemeinschaftlichen Schalten immer versucht habe, zwischen 45 und 60 Minuten zu bleiben pro Verein. Jetzt sind wir regelmäßig bei 1.15, 1.20, 1.30. Ich lasse es auch mehr oder weniger laufen, weil ich schon weiß, wenn ich versuche zu hetzen oder Dinge weglasse, dann wird genau das vorgeworfen werden in den Kommentaren. Ihr habt ja diesen Aspekt gar nicht besprochen. Bedeutet aber, dass der Zeitaufwand noch mal größer wird und dass zusätzliche veröffentlichen, was ja schon, also zusätzlich zur Sendung würde ich sagen, sind es bei jeder Sendung noch mal anderthalb Stunden, bis es wirklich auf jedem Kanal überall gepostet ist und so weiter. Das ist schon ein Brett. Und das merke ich jetzt auch gerade beim Royale. Ich mag es sehr, dass jetzt viel passiert. Ich merke aber auch, dass mich das Verfolgen des Feedbacks total überfordert. Und jetzt erinnere ich mich auch wieder daran, dass ich ja früher beim Royale oft tatsächlich die ersten zwei, drei Tage sehr untypisch für mich das Handy mal mehr oder weniger ausgemacht habe und gar nicht gelesen habe. Da habe ich manchmal auch Aufreger erst mitbekommen, wenn sich die Community schon wieder gegenseitig beruhigt hatte, dass es so schlimm ja vielleicht doch nicht war, was irgendein Gast gesagt hat. Das ist jetzt manchmal ein bisschen viel. Da gab es auch richtig schlechte Momente jetzt, aber da muss ich noch ein bisschen drüber nachdenken, was das jetzt für die Zukunft heißt. Inhaltlich funktioniert es sehr gut. Der Aufwand ist aber wirklich extrem durch das ständige Veröffentlichen, weil es auch so viele Plattformen sind, auf denen wir veröffentlichen. Also es geht in eine Podcast-Feed, es geht zu einer anderen Uhrzeit bei YouTube online, weil ansonsten zerschießen wir uns da den Algorithmus. Erst wenn es auf YouTube ist, kann ich es auf Instagram und bei mir in den Status posten. Twitter, Blue Sky und Mastodon mache ich aber immer, wenn ich es auf die Seite gebaut habe. Auf die Seite kann ich es aber erst bauen, wenn es im Podcast-Feed erschienen ist. Das ist schon, also im Grunde mache ich gerade nichts anderes jetzt, seitdem der Royale losgegangen ist, als Sendung aufnehmen, Sendung vorbereiten, Sendung posten, Feedback lesen. Also schon viel, aber es funktioniert mega gut, finde ich. Also inhaltlich finde ich es toll. Und vor allem haben mir schon ganz viele Leute gesagt, dass sie mit Abstand noch mal alte Sendungen gehört haben. Und das war nämlich das, was ich immer schon gesagt habe, was aber leider sich nie etabliert hat innerhalb unserer Community. Hört euch alte Schwerpunkte an, hört euch alte Rasenfunk-Royalfolgen an. Hannover 96 in ihrem letzten Erstligajahr, das ist super interessant, weil man hat einfach so viel wieder vergessen. Und das ist, da bin ich jetzt einfach mal so arrogant, das zu sagen, in dieser Kompaktheit, dass du innerhalb von einer Stunde dann die wichtigen Themen einer Saison bekommst, das gibt es gar nicht so oft in der Podcast-Landschaft.
Vor allem nicht mehr abrufbar. Also in der Podcast-Landschaft, natürlich, da wäre es abrufbar, aber an allen anderen Stellen ist es einfach nicht mehr zugreifbar.
Genau, und ich habe mir das öfter gedacht. Ich meine, bei Fleben und beim Buch, das dann daraus geworden ist, ging es ja ganz oft darum, noch mal einen Saisonverlauf mitzuverfolgen. Und da habe ich mir ganz oft gedacht, boah, hätte es da mal schon Podcast gegeben, da würde ich mir jetzt einfach da ein paar Sendungen anhören. Und dann wüsste ich, dass ich alles weiß. Und man kriegt das bei Vereinspodcasts. Da ist es natürlich auch noch tiefer, aber das ist halt dann vielleicht auch manchmal das Problem. Bei denen dauert halt dann die Saison, der Saisonrückblick dauert dreieinhalb Stunden. Bei uns halt dann eine Stunde. Deswegen, ich kann es wirklich nur empfehlen, hört euch alte Rasenfunk-Folgen an. Skippt halt zu den Schwerpunkten, weil die Spielbesprechung ist dann wirklich nicht mehr so interessant. Aber das ist wirklich, und ich hoffe, dass das jetzt mit der neuen, mit der neuen Konzeption funktioniert. Dass man viel einfacher jetzt einfach das FC Bayern-Segment von nach dieser Saison hört, auch nochmal in fünf Jahren.
Ja, das glaube ich definitiv. Und Spoiler Alert, Max hat gerade elf Leben gesagt. Dazu haben wir auch noch was später. Nächstes Thema, weitere Moderatorinnen. Da geht es konkret einmal mehr. Ich glaube, die Frage hatten wir tatsächlich schon ein paar Mal. Wie es denn aussieht, ob da was in Sicht wäre, dass man dich mehr zeitlich unterstützt? Ist es finanziell drin, dass wir regelmäßige Moderatoren einsetzen? Oder gibt es andere Gründe, warum wir es bisher noch nicht so oft tun, wie wir es vielleicht könnten?
Ich glaube nicht so arg viel Neues. Ihr kennt ja die Stimmen, die immer mal wieder hier zu hören sind. Es gab auch durchaus noch andere Menschen, denen ich angeboten habe, mal zu moderieren. Aber zwei Dinge muss man halt dazu sagen. Das eine ist, dass die Rückmeldung ist, dass es schon was sehr Anstrengendes ist, einen Rasenfunk zu moderieren, egal ob zur Bundesliga der Frauen oder zur Bundesliga der Männer. Weil eben neben dem ganzen Inhaltlichen eben auch das Produzieren der Folge dazu gehört. Und viel von den Posten der Folge übernehme ja dann immer noch ich. Also die Leute stellen es online, es ist im Feed, und ich mache da Newsletter, Social Media und so weiter. Und manchmal sogar noch YouTube. Also das ist die Rückmeldung, dass mir selbst Leute, die meiner Meinung nach genauso oder noch härter arbeiten, sagen, boah, das ist schon ein ganz schönes Brett. Das könnte ich jetzt nicht jedes Wochenende machen. Zum anderen ist es so, dass die Menschen andere Berufe haben, was ich schwer verurteile, aber wir können halt niemanden fest anstellen. Und ja, also das ist glaube ich so das, wo sich noch am meisten verändern muss eigentlich im Rasenfunk. Eigentlich müsstet ihr mich seltener hören da draußen.
Aber es ist schwierig, eben aus den genannten Gründen. Es gibt Gründe, warum es nicht so viele gibt, die das in ähnlicher Ausführlichkeit machen.
Ja und überlegt einfach mal, liebe HörerInnen, wie würdet ihr jetzt reagieren, wenn die Hälfte der Royalsendungen nicht von mir moderiert worden wären? Und wenn es dann in Anführungszeichen euren Verein betrifft. Ich habe die Angst, dass es dann zum Thema gemacht wird. Das wäre dann total ungerecht gegenüber den ModeratorInnen, die sich ja auch mit sehr viel Mühe vorbereitet haben, aber die halt logischerweise nicht 31 Spiele des Teams gesehen haben und nicht mein riesen Dokument haben. Das könnte ich denen zwar geben, aber das hilft denen nichts, weil ich habe da so eine gewisse Kodierung in meiner Sprache inzwischen entwickelt. Und davor habe ich, vielleicht bin ich da auch zu eingebildet, ich weiß es nicht, aber davor habe ich manchmal so ein bisschen Angst, dass wenn man mal so einen Schritt wirklich gehen würde, dass dann die Leute damit auch nicht zufrieden wären. Und wenn jetzt kritisiert wird, dann wird in der Regel an meiner Arbeit kritisiert. Und da ist mir wohl dabei, als wenn die Arbeit von anderen kritisiert wird. Das tut mir dann immer sehr leid für die.
Okay, haben wir das geklärt. Dann geht es um die Veröffentlichung. Sonntag oder Montag ist ja eigentlich in der Regel. Das sind die beiden Tage, an denen die Bundesliga-Analyse veröffentlicht wird. Stadion Pfarrer 1889, 1898. Ja, ja, natürlich. Ich war gerade nur unkonzentriert bei der Zahl. Wollte da wissen, was das denn, warum, was ist die Entscheidung, was sind die Aspekte, die dazu beitragen. Er empfindet tendenziell die Sendung, die erst nach einer Nacht Schlaf aufgenommen wurden, als etwas entspannter.
Ja, kann sein, dass sie sind, weiß ich aber nicht. Ich glaube, so generell kann man das nicht sagen. Die Antwort ist ganz einfach. Ich habe es auch schon mal irgendwann hier im Rasenfunk gesagt. Die Hälfte der Zeit sind meine Kinder bei mir, die Hälfte der Zeit sind sie bei ihrer Mutter, die Hälfte der Wochenenden sind sie bei mir. Und jetzt könnt ihr einfach überlegen, liebe Hörerinnen, wann guckt denn der Max die ganzen Fußballspiele, wenn die Kinder da sind? Weil der macht es ja nicht, wenn die Kinder da sind. Das mache ich natürlich abends. Und dann, also ihr könnt indirekt, nicht komplett zum Glück, aber indirekt könnt ihr ein bisschen eine Ahnung bekommen, wie mein Wochenende aussah. Anhand der Frage, erscheint eine Folge am Sonntagabend oder Montagvormittag. Es hat allerdings auch manchmal mit Gästen zu tun, deswegen ist jetzt nicht immer komplett davon abhängig. Aber das ist der Hauptgrund, weil manchmal muss ich halt Mont, Sonntagabend erst noch die Spiele gucken, und dann kann ich dazu noch keine Sendung machen.
Ein bisschen einfacher ist es auch, weil Max jetzt Unterstützung hat, nämlich von Moritz. Den Namensgag haben wir uns nicht absichtlich so ausgesucht. Der ist reiner Zufall. Aber den Naini Brock würde interessieren, wie die Zusammenarbeit läuft mit Moritz, zwischen dir, Max und Moritz. Und ob die erhoffte Entlastung schon eingetreten ist.
Also zum Glück läuft die Zusammenarbeit super, weil ich hätte ein totales Problem damit, öffentlich ansonsten über jemanden zu sprechen, mit dem ich zusammenarbeite. Aber ich kann voll in Herzen sagen, alles wunderbar, es ist eine Entlastung. Trotzdem bleibt noch, also mir ist jetzt bewusst geworden, wie viel Arbeit ich sonst noch so neben der Gäste-Orga mache. Weil in meinem Kopf dachte ich auch, Mensch, super, und dann macht das alles der Moritz. Und ich muss nicht mehr die mitwirkenden Verträge verschicken. Und de facto habe ich aber trotzdem immer noch ganz gut zu tun. Aber ich bin heidenfroh, dass wir Moritz mit im Team haben, dass er uns hilft. Und vor allem in den Notfallsituationen hat das bisher sehr geholfen. Also in den Wochen, wo wir trotz aller Vorplanung am Freitagvormittag noch keinen Gast haben für die Sendung am Sonntagabend. Oder wenn ich ehrlicherweise vergessen hatte zwischen all den Sendungen, dass in der nächsten Woche schon wieder eine Zweitligatur ansteht, für die ich noch drei Gäste suchen muss, ist es eine irre Entlastung, dass ich, egal in welcher Lebenssituation ich mich gerade befinde, dem Moritz schreiben kann, Moritz, schlag doch mal drei Vereine vor und drei Gäste. Das klappt alles ganz wunderbar. Es ist eine große Entlastung. Ich bin sehr froh, dass wir Moritz im Team haben.
Wunderbar. Damit können wir auch den Blog-Struktur und Organisation abschließen und wenden uns dem Thema Refinanzierung und Honorare zu. Jetzt wird es ein bisschen trocken. Der Yuvi wollte wissen, ob wir ein bisschen Einblick in die GmbH-Bilanz geben können. Da können wir ein paar Act-Daten sagen, wie sich das jetzt verteilt, wohin das Geld fließt, das wir von euch als Unterstützer bekommen. Max hat da ein paar Zahlen, ein paar Act-Daten.
Irgendwann wird das hoffentlich auch Teil unserer Webseite sein. Transparenzbericht in großen Anführungszeichen, nicht auf den Centenaren, aber so eine grobe Verwendung des Geldes, was wir von euch bekommen. Der Grund dafür, dass wir das noch nicht gemacht haben, war zweierlei. Als der Rasenfunk noch eine Einzelfirma war, bevor wir zur GmbH wurden, da war ehrlicherweise so viel im Fluss, dass das schwer auseinander zu dröseln war, wegen auch vieler Dinge, die wir für den Job gekauft haben und so weiter und so fort. Da hast du überlappende Geschäftsjahre. Und jetzt mit der GmbH wollten wir eben den Jahresabschluss, die Jahresbilanz von 2023, abwarten, weil wir erst dann sagen konnten, welche Kosten sind jetzt eigentlich noch zum Beispiel beim Erstellen dieses Jahresabschlusses entstanden, weil das sowieso schon eine Erfahrung war. Wir wussten schon vorher darüber, aber an welchen Ecken man dann doch nochmal Geld zahlt als GmbH. Also hin und wieder dachte ich mir, ach so, ja, ihr wollt auch noch was von uns. Na gut, dann weiß ich nicht, ob es dir da ähnlich ging oder ob du da noch besser informiert warst. Na ja, deswegen wollten wir diesen Jahresabschluss abwarten, bevor wir euch mal so einen groben Überblick geben wollten. Und den können wir jetzt aber geben. Grundsätzlich, es geht dem Rasenfunk finanziell sehr gut. Ihr habt ein irres Support-Pensum gestemmt im letzten Jahr. Das hat auch dazu geführt, dass wir mit einem kleinen Gewinn aus dem Jahr rausgegangen sind, den wir, also wir planen vernünftig. Wir wollen jetzt hier keine, wir wollen uns nicht an den Bundesligisten orientieren, sondern wir legen dann immer wieder Geld zurück und können davon dann weitere Projekte zahlen. Und man weiß ja auch nie, was so ganz passiert. Das heißt, wir gehen mit einem kleinen Gewinn aus dem letzten Jahr raus. Und ich kann euch jetzt so grob sagen, wie sich unsere Kosten verteilen. Und zwar, wenn wir einfach von 10 Euro ausgehen, die ihr uns überweist, dann kann man sagen, 6,50 Euro, also 65 Prozent, gehen an die Gäste und gehen an Frank und an mich. Das war die Verteilung, wie wir sie im letzten Jahr hatten. Wir hatten dann 1,10 Euro, also 11 Prozent, die haben wir für Materialaufwendung. Das sind Dinge, die wir für den Shop gekauft haben. Auch so Verpackungsmaterial ist da mit dabei. Anschaffungen anderer Art, die wir gemacht haben, Headsets und so weiter. Dann 13 Prozent, also 1,30 Euro, geht drauf für Software, Instandhaltung, Versicherungen. Diesem ganzen großen Themenkomplex und auch sowas wie Buchhaltungskosten etc. Und 11 Prozent zahlen wir tatsächlich an Steuern, das heißt 1,11 Euro. Das heißt nochmal, weil das jetzt sehr schnell ging, also von 10 Euro gehen 6,50 Euro an Gäste und an Frank und mich. 1,10 Euro waren irgendwelche Materialaufwendungen, die wir in diesem Jahr hatten, ganz verschiedener Art. 1,30 Euro waren Instandhaltungskosten, Software usw. und 1,10 Euro Steuern, die wir gezahlt haben.
Genau, und bevor jetzt jemand sagt, was, ihr zahlt nur 11 Prozent Steuern? Nein, das sind natürlich 11 Prozent vom Umsatz. Schön wär's. Genau, also wir zahlen als GmbH, Körperschafts- und Gewerbesteuer ganz regelrecht natürlich auf den Gewinn bezogen. Aber am Umsatz sind das insgesamt 11 Prozent, damit ihr einfach mal wisst, wo das Geld so hinfließt.
Genau, das scheint mir auch eine ganz gesunde Verteilung zu sein. Also das wird sich auch über die Jahre hinweg leicht verändern, weil wenn wir jetzt eben den Shop einstampfen, wie ihr ja schon alle mitbekommen habt, dann ist natürlich das Ziel, dass dann irgendwann die Materialkosten runtergehen. Und irgendwann ist hoffentlich auch unser AV dann leer. Also in dem Sinne dann leer, dass wir da nichts mehr im Lager und auch nicht mehr in der Bilanz rumliegen haben. Das sollte dann runtergehen. Dafür sind halt solche Posten wie eben Software, Hostingkosten und so weiter. Da sind so Variable mit drin. Wenn wir mal wieder was an der Homepage machen, da kann es ein bisschen steigen. Ich muss aber sagen, ich bin sehr zufrieden mit den 65 Prozent, die in Gäste und uns fließen, weil das scheint mir ein vernünftiger Prozentsatz zu sein. Es ist nicht so viel, dass wir dem Rasenfunk die finanzielle Luft zum Atmen nehmen. Wir sind flexibel. Es kann jetzt auch mal was passieren. Oder wir können uns eben auch, wir können mal etwas wagen, so wie wir es letztes Jahr gemacht haben mit Annika zur WM der Frauen. Und es ist aber auch nicht so wenig, dass man sagt, hey, ich will doch eigentlich euch unterstützen und nicht irgendwas anderes. Also ich bin zufrieden damit. Ich bin gespannt, wie die Hörerinnen da draußen es sehen.
Geht dahin und kauft den leer.
Wir brauchen diese ganzen Tassen nicht.
Da war noch eine Anschlussfrage, wie wir denn mit der GmbH zufrieden sind. Ob es vielleicht ein anderes Modell bräuchte, eine Stiftung oder eine Genossenschaft. Ehrlicherweise kann ich da gar nicht seriös darauf antworten. Wir sind allerdings mit dem GmbH-Modell sehr zufrieden. Der Sinn und Zweck, das ein bisschen auf robustere Unternehmensbeine zu stellen, also jetzt ein Einzelunternehmen, ist damit völlig erfüllt. Ich glaube nicht, dass es eine andere Gesellschaftsform braucht. Wenn ihr das doch denkt, könnt ihr das gerne noch mal im Forum ein bisschen detaillierter erörtern. Aber ich sehe ehrlich gesagt nicht, warum das so sein sollte. Weil am Ende sind wir zwar komplett höher finanziert, höher innenfinanziert, aber am Ende sind wir doch ein Unternehmen und müssen ja auch in einer kapitalistischen Gesellschaft existieren. Also es spricht überhaupt nichts dagegen, dass der Rasenfunk einfach ein Unternehmen ist. Und wir bemühen uns nach allen Kräften, das mit gutem unternehmerischen Handeln zu füllen. Insofern zahlen wir da unterm Strich auch gern Steuern für. Also es gibt jetzt aus meiner Sicht keine wirklichen Gründe, irgendwas daran zu ändern, aber wir sind beide hier, Max und ich, nicht allwissend, was das angeht. Also wenn ihr da wertvollen Input habt, dann gerne immer raus damit. Wenn ihr das nicht öffentlich machen wollt, auch gerne per Direktnachricht im Forum. So, dann ist in diesem ganzen Themenkomplex eigentlich nur noch eine Frage offen und zwar, wie entwickeln sich denn die Honorare so?
Die Gesamtzahl ist immer noch gleichbleibend zum Vorjahr, grob, leicht gestiegen. Tatsächlich war mit der Umstrukturierung der Sendung auch damit verbunden, dass wir die Honorare anpassen mussten. Wir hatten immer so einen Dreier Schritt aus verschiedenen Höhen, die wir gezahlt haben. Wenn du in der letzten Saison in einer Analysesendung zu Gast warst, dann hast du noch mehr bekommen als in einer aktuellen Sendung. Auch weil wir gesagt haben, wir haben versucht, das so auch quasi fair zu machen, weil jetzt ja nicht mehr erwartet wird, dass du alle neun Spiele vorbereitest. Auch deshalb diese Trennung zwischen vier und fünf Spielen. Es gibt natürlich immer noch genügend Gäste, die freiwillig dann alle Spiele gucken. Aber auch daher kam das. So konnten wir das finanzieren, weil wir ja letztlich einen Gast pro Woche mehr haben, durch den Fokus, der ausgelagert ist. Und deswegen, da mussten wir quasi Honorare reduzieren. War aber, also nach dem Feedback, was ich bekommen habe, kein… Ich wurde eher ausgelacht, als ich das erklärt habe, von einigen, muss ich ehrlicherweise sagen. Deswegen, Honorare sind auf ähnlichem Niveau geblieben. Und insgesamt haben wir mehr Honorare gezahlt, weil wir mehr Sendungen produziert haben. Das wird jetzt dann in dem Jahr dann nochmal gesteigert werden, weil wir nochmal mehr Sendungen produzieren. Und dann hoffe ich, dass wir dann irgendwann drüber reden können, ob wir dann an den Honoraren nochmal etwas nach oben gehen. Aber das muss man halt wirtschaftlich vernünftig machen, weil es sind eben wirklich sehr viele. Also ich weiß gerade gar nicht, ich glaube im Jahr 2023 habe ich 280 Honorar-Abrechnungen, also so ungefähr, geschrieben. Und wenn wir jetzt einfach mal sagen, jede davon 5 Euro mehr, dann könnt ihr euch ja selber ausrechnen, das ist schon was. Also das können wir sich einfach so machen.
Damit haben wir diesen Komplex abgeschlossen und gehen jetzt über zur Resonanz, also zu dem, was am Ende in Sachen Reichweite und so herauskommt. Und da ging die erste Frage darum, ob mehr Output denn auch mehr Reichweite bedeutet. Also ist der erhöhte Output denn in der Reichweite zu spüren?
Ich würde sagen, das ist sehr plattformabhängig. Also bei YouTube, du hast es ja vorhin schon angedeutet, haben wir ein ganz tolles Wachstum hingelegt, sind von 6000 AbonnentInnen im April letzten Jahres jetzt bei 10.500. Und da wachsen wir. Ich bilde mir auch ein, dass immer mal wieder neue Leute den Rasenfunk hören, die ich vorher noch nirgendwo den Rasenfunk habe hören sehen, gerade die Einzelsendungen, also die Fokus-Sendungen, die sind halt auch jetzt einfacher, in irgendwelchen Foren zu posten und dann noch anzuhören. Vorher war es halt so, ja hier, spul mal zu zwei Stunden acht Minuten, da geht es dann rund um den VfL Bochum. Jetzt schickst du einfach einen Link und sagst, hörst du es mal an. Also ich würde behaupten, ja, wir haben mehr Reichweite durch das Mehr an Output, was aber logischerweise ja erstmal auch ein mathematischer Effekt ist, weil es eine gewisse Anzahl an Downloads gibt. Deswegen muss man da jetzt vorsichtig sein, sich jetzt nicht auf irgendwelche Zahlen was einzubilden. Die Zahlen sind, glaube ich, alle gut. Und das hängt aber halt auch mit dem hohen Output zusammen. Deswegen ja, mehr Reichweite durch mehr Output. Aber was es wirklich heißt, da müssen wir noch ein bisschen abwarten, oder?
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Dirion schließt sich da ein bisschen an an die Frage, ob es denn noch Wachstum gibt oder ob da so eine Gläser, eine Decke erreicht ist. Ich glaube, wir haben das in der Vergangenheit schon mal gesagt, dass sich zum Beispiel die Bundesliga-Analyse schwer tut mit Wachstum. Auch das war ein Grund, warum wir YouTube verstärkt haben, weil wir gesehen haben, da gibt es Wachstum. Das war ja eben auch, was Max schon sagte, dass er das Gefühl hat, dass er bei YouTube immer mal noch neue vorbeikommen. Das ist mit Sicherheit auch das größte Potenziale im Moment. Und am Ende ist ja auch, da kommen wir auch gleich im nächsten Abschnitt nochmal dazu, dieses Thema Social Video, also TikTok, Short Videos bei YouTube, Instagram Reels. Der Grund, warum wir da aktiv geworden sind, ist ja auch ein bisschen, um da auszuloten, was eventuell an Wachstumspotenzial für uns drinsteckt.
Genau. Und die Frage, die da natürlich auch immer kommt, ist, müsst ihr wachsen? In kleinen Rahmen auf jeden Fall, weil es gibt halt einfach eine Anzahl an Menschen, die hört auf, den Rasenfunk zu hören, aus den unterschiedlichsten Gründen. Und dafür brauchen wir einen konstanten Strom an Leuten, die nachkommen. Und für ganz viele Aspekte, die wir vorhin im Teil Inhaltliches und Strukturen und Organisationen hatten, da ist halt neben Zeit Geld oft der limitierende Faktor. Also wir wollen ja nicht deshalb wachsen, weil wir zwei in Lamborghini brauchen. Das wird auch schwer mit dem Rasenfunk, obwohl ihr uns so toll supportet, sondern weil wir eben dieses Format Rasenfunk weiterentwickeln wollen. Und da muss man schon sagen, der Gesamtmarkt zu Audio-Inhalten, die sich mit Fußball beschäftigen, der hat sich einfach krass gewandelt und das hat in diesem Jahr nochmal zugenommen. Und ich bin sehr gespannt, wie das zur EM wird. Denn bisher war es so, dass Turniere für uns immer sehr wichtig waren. Die waren ähnlich wichtig wie der Royale. Da haben wir oft hohe Reichweiten gehabt und da haben wir oft neue Leute für den Rasenfunk interessiert. Allein dadurch, dass wir eben ganz lange Zeit das einzige oder eins von wenigen Formaten waren, das eben zu jedem Spiel eine Sendung gemacht hat, das sich Zeit genommen hat für eine Vorschau und so weiter und so fort. In diesem Sommer wird das ziemlich sicher anders sein. Da werdet ihr jetzt schon mit täglichen Fußballpodcasts zugeballert. Das hat immer mehr zugenommen, das ist der aktuelle Trend. Das heißt, zur EM wird es nicht mehr so sein, dass wir allein dadurch, dass wir jeden Tag eine Folge machen oder mindestens eine, schon mal Reichweite bekommen, sondern wir werden da anstinken. Wir werden hinter den Freundes, Kickers, Sport1, Sky und Springers dieser Welt finden wir irgendwo auf Platz 15 statt. Da guckt keiner mehr hin. Das heißt, das ist schon... Also manchmal verspüre ich da schon so einen Druck, muss ich sagen, den wir als Ansporn verstehen. Aber ich glaube, wir dürften uns jetzt nicht auf dem ausruhen, was wir aktuell machen, alles nur so weitermachen. Dann kann es schon sein, dass so Schleichen der Rasenfunkprobleme bekäme.
Ja, und dann kommen wir noch gleich zu dem Social-Video, das ich gerade schon angesprochen habe. Sind da schon Effekte spürbar, Max, durch die Veröffentlichung? Also für all diejenigen, die es noch nicht mitbekommen haben, vielleicht kurz zusammengefasst, wir veröffentlichen seit Anfang des Jahres ungefähr nach vielen Sendungen einen kurzen Hotcut, würde ich es mal sagen, von maximal 60 Sekunden bei TikTok als YouTube Short und als Instagram Real mit dem Grunde den knackigsten Aussagen der Sendung, mit den interessantesten Segmenten, das lassen wir, da kommen wir auch gleich nochmal dazu, von einem freien Cutter, mittlerweile sind es zwei, die wir dafür haben, produzieren. Max gibt dann nach der Sendung da so ein paar Ausschnitte durch ein paar Timecodes, exportiert entsprechende Segmente aus den Videos und das wird dann von dem Cutter für uns gemacht und danach wird es veröffentlicht. Jetzt ist die Frage, was war denn da bisher das Ergebnis? Kann man da irgendwas daraus lesen, Max? Gab es irgendwo eine Entwicklung in diesen Profilen? Gab es spürbare Auswirkungen auf die Feeds, auf die Hauptformate?
Also die spürbaren Auswirkungen auf die Hauptformate, die gab es noch nicht, aber das wäre jetzt auch noch nicht zu erwarten, muss man sagen. Das zum einen und zum anderen müssen das dann auch schon hohe Zahlen sein, damit die sich bemerkbar machen. Weil, um jetzt den Unterschied zu merken zwischen, keine Ahnung, 30.000 und 32.000 Downloads, müssen es halt schon 2.000 sein. Die Tausend, die mehr dazu kommen, die merken wir dann erstmal gar nicht so wirklich. Der Grund, warum wir das gemacht haben und der Grund, warum ich das noch nie im Rasenfunk erwähnt habe, dass wir jetzt bei TikTok sind, das ist jetzt tatsächlich eine Premiere, liebe HörerInnen, liegt daran, dass es eine Subkultur gibt von Fußball-Video-Content, in der der Rasenfunk nicht stattfindet. Und diese Subkultur, die kennt auch den Rasenfunk nicht, und zwar bei weitem nicht. Und deswegen war das Ziel, deswegen habe ich das nie im Rasenfunk gesagt, dass wir jetzt auch bei TikTok sind. Irgendwie freuen wir uns natürlich, wenn ihr uns alle da folgt, aber eigentlich wollten wir neue Leute da finden. Und wir wollten quasi dem Algorithmus auch die Möglichkeit bieten, uns neue Leute anzubieten und eben nicht quasi gleich wieder unsere Blase nachzubilden, die wir sowieso schon haben. Und das funktioniert sehr gut. Logischerweise funktioniert es nach den Mechanismen dieser Videoplattformen, die natürlich eigentlich doof sind und auch nicht so ganz zum Rasenfunk passen, nämlich je hotter der Take, desto heißer das Thema, oder desto netter der Zusammenschnitt, desto mehr wird darüber diskutiert. Ich bin aber sehr glücklich damit, dass wir, obwohl wir auch schon ein paar virale Videos hatten mit fünfstelligen View-Anzahlen, dass wir da bisher uns noch nicht schmutzig machen mussten. Also es wurde, logischerweise, es würden wir ja nie machen wollen. Aber wir haben noch nie irgendwas sinnverdreht zusammengeschnitten. Die Videos sind immer noch viel weniger knallig als die von anderen Teams, einfach weil, wenn jemand bei uns einen Nebensatz zu einem Team sagt, dann kommt der auch so halb ins Video noch und wird nicht irgendwie nach dem dritten Wort schon abgeschnitten und dann kommt der nächste Take rein. Also ich finde, in diesem Bereich Video-Kurzformate zu Fußball sind wir immer noch eines der ausgeruhteren Formate und das passt ja auch zum Rasenfunk. Und die Frage des Erfolges würde ich ja dann daran messen, sehen, dass Leute, die uns vorher nicht kannten, und da kann ich mit einem ganz entschiedenen Ja antworten, denn die Hauptantwort ist ganz oft, wer ist der Typ mit der Brille, warum redet der so, was willst du eigentlich, ihr habt doch alle keine Ahnung. Aber auch zum Teil natürlich inhaltliches Feedback, ich will jetzt gar nicht hier irgendwie ein TikTok-Bashing übergehen. Und das ist super, weil bei solchen Leuten will ich einfach nur platzieren, schau mal, es gäbe auch den Rasenfunk, vielleicht ist es was für dich. Und für fünf von hundert ist es dann was, und die wechseln dann vielleicht auch irgendwann die Plattform, weil ihnen dann die Einminutenschnipsel nicht mehr reichen, dann hören sie mal eine Sendung rein, egal auf welcher Plattform. Aber das muss halt noch wachsen. Aber ich bin eigentlich sehr zufrieden damit, und ich weiß nicht, wie es dir geht, ich war total gespannt darauf zu sehen, wie die ersten Einminutenzusammenschnitte von so 15-Minuten-Segmenten aus der Sendung sein würden. Und inhaltlich finde ich es dann immer selber, also man denkt sich selber manchmal, Mensch, ist ja krass, was wir eigentlich alles besprochen haben in diesem 15-Minuten-Segment, das ist schon cool.
Also ich muss sagen, ich bin ein bisschen positiv überrascht davon, wie gut das funktioniert als Video. Jetzt nicht, funktioniert auf der Plattform, da kann man sicherlich dann drüber streiten und da hängt natürlich vieles noch davon ab, dass wir besser sichtbar werden müssen und sowas, von vielen kleinen Details. Aber wie gut das funktioniert, diese Schnipsel aus so einer Analysesendung rauszunehmen und was Aussagekräftiges hinzubekommen, was natürlich immer, aber ich meine, ich konsumiere nun auch, war auch nicht der Erste, der mit TikTok als Konsument angefangen hat, aber konsumiere nun auch seit einem Jahr oder so relativ regelmäßig, TikTok weniger, meistens YouTube oder Instagram. Man gewöhnt sich so ein bisschen an diese Kurzformate und ich finde, das funktioniert relativ gut. Ich kann mir gut vorstellen, dass es als Teaser, als Anreiz funktioniert. Ob es dann tatsächlich so ist, dass wir das irgendwann als Ergebnis in den Statistiken sehen, steht natürlich in den Sternen, ist dann eben auch, wie anfangs erwähnt, fraglich, ob wir es überhaupt entdecken würden. Ich denke, es wird jetzt auf absehbare Zeit, denn wir haben keinerlei negativen Outcome bisher damit, außer dass es Geld kostet, da kann man vielleicht auch noch einen kurzen Takt dazu sagen, aber ansonsten ist es durchweg positiv, der Ablauf funktioniert, die Veröffentlichung funktioniert. Wir werden das auf jeden Fall eine Weile durchziehen, auch schon müssen, um irgendwann zu entscheiden, lohnt es sich oder nicht.
Ja, das ist absolut wahr, aber ich möchte noch mal strapazieren, da gibt es eben eine eigene Subkultur, die sich rausbildet. Und es geht uns ja auch nicht immer bei allem, was wir machen, darum, immer mehr Reichweite und mehr Wachstum und mehr Geld zu haben. Ich denke, da spreche ich für uns beide, wir probieren halt einfach auch sehr gerne Sachen aus. Und wir sind schon beide so lange im Internet aktiv, dass wir schon mehrere Dinge sich entwickeln und wieder eingehen haben sehen. Aber die aktuellen Trends, die eben so Kurzformatvideos angeht, die werden nicht mehr weggehen. Das wird sich eher tatsächlich noch verschärfen. Und wir beide haben halt da eine Freude daran, dann da mitzumischen und zu gucken, können wir da nach unseren Konditionen, können wir da mitmachen und dann vielleicht auch Erfolg haben. Aber wenn wir jetzt in einem Jahr TikTok wieder zumachen würden oder nicht mehr so viel dafür bezahlen würden für Videos, und wir hätten keine 1000 Follower erreicht, also ich würde da nicht weit ins Bett gehen. Ich freue mich darüber, dass wir das jetzt mal ausprobieren und mal ein paar neue Leute dadurch kennenlernen.
Und ich glaube, es gibt auch noch den Aspekt, dass es ja auch für uns die Möglichkeit gibt, herauszufinden, ob wir in einem Medium, in dem wir bisher nicht vertreten waren, die Möglichkeit haben, mit Inhalten, wie wir sie uns vorstellen, und dann eben auch in kurzer Form, die sich ja immer noch unterscheiden von den Aussagen, die andere tätigen in dieser kurzen Zeit, und die wir ja bekommen, weil wir die Gäste einladen, die wir gut finden, da einfach auch unsere Inhalte platzieren können. Zwar nicht in der gewohnt langen Form, aber trotzdem ja unsere Inhalte, wofür wir stehen, die Gäste stehen, worauf wir stolz sind. Und ich finde, das ist auch ein Aspekt. Selbst wenn es mal nur für sich alleine funktioniert und sich gar nicht so sehr auf die Feeds auswirkt, kann es vielleicht auch positive Aspekte haben. Ob das dann am Ende was zur Refinanzierung beitragen kann, ist dann natürlich nochmal eine andere Frage. Und wie gesagt, auf der anderen Seite stehen Kosten. Also Finanzierung ist natürlich ein Thema unterm Strich. Aber erst mal muss es jetzt quasi als Test erst mal so funktionieren.
Bringt uns ja auch zu dem Aspekt, der ja auch nachgefragt wurde, ob die zusätzliche Videoproduktion für uns ein organisatorisches Problem geworden ist oder in sonstiger Form. Ich kann mal kurz das schildern, was sich für mich verändert hat. Also zum einen hat es dazu geführt, dass die Rasenfunk GmbH mir einen neuen Laptop bezahlen musste, denn der alte Rechner ist beim Rendering nicht mehr zurechtgekommen der Videos, dafür waren die zu lang. Wie war das? Ich glaube, ich hatte 1,1-fache Geschwindigkeit beim Rendering, der damals noch Schlusskonferenz, und dann wisst ihr ja, das musste ich dann über Nacht machen lassen, und wenn dann aber irgendwas schiefgegangen ist beim Rendering, musste ich es nochmal anstoßen. Jetzt habe ich hier einen neuen Laptop stehen, der war schon in den Materialkosten mit drin, die ich euch vorhin genannt habe. Das war das eine, was sich verändert hat. Das andere ist natürlich, dass sich mein Workflow jetzt verlängert hat. Also ich muss jetzt mehr Dinge machen, aber ich schaffe es inzwischen ganz gut, da nicht zu viel Zeit zu verlieren, und deshalb sind die Videos auch so rudimentär. Links der eine, rechts der andere, oder wenn es drei sind, ich in der Mitte, und die anderen beiden Gäste links und rechts. Das ist immer gleich, es gibt keine Zwischenschnitte, es gibt keine Bauchbinden, ich blende nicht den Namen des Kapitels ein, weil das sind alles Fehlerquellen und es kostet alles Zeit. Es geht relativ schnell, aber auch nur wegen des neuen Rechners, muss man wirklich sagen, weil der einfach sehr schnell rausrendert. Was noch dazugekommen ist, ist immer der Zusatzaufwand für Video-Schnipsel. Das hast du ja schon gesagt, da bauen wir immer einen kleinen Abbinder und ich lasse nochmal so ein Segment raus. Und was natürlich auch mehr Zeit kostet, ist dann der Upload zu YouTube. Ich meine, ich habe jetzt gerade, heute Vormittag habe ich das Schiedsrichter-Segment hochgeladen zu YouTube. Ich weiß gerade gar nicht, wann das bei YouTube erscheinen wird. Das waren drei Stunden 30, 17 Gigabyte. Also das mache ich dann auch nicht parallel zu der Sendung. Genau, muss man sagen. Aber ich finde, dass es eigentlich alles im Rahmen läuft. Und generell muss man sagen, die Videoproduktion, sie kostet Geld, sie kostet Zeit. Vielleicht kannst du gleich auch nochmal deine Meinung dazu sagen. Sie hat aber die Sendungen auch für die Podcast-Only-HörerInnen besser gemacht. Denn das, die Gäste, das wir uns jetzt sehen, ich hätte nie gedacht, welchen Effekt das haben würde auf Sendungen. Es ist viel, viel entspannter. Es ist gerade für Neulinge viel angenehmer. Denn vorher müsst ihr euch vorstellen, da haben die einen Browser-Tab vor sich gesehen und da konnten sie ihren Ausschlag sehen und den Ausschlag von Gästen, wenn sie was gesprochen haben, aber sie konnten sonst nichts sehen. Und jetzt bist du neu in einem Format und der Max stellt dir irgendeine geschlossene Frage, auf die es eigentlich eh schon keine ordentliche Antwort gibt. Und dann fängst du an zu reden und du redest eine Minute, zwei Minuten, drei Minuten und da wirst du unsicher, denn du bekommst kein Feedback. Auch deshalb habe ich früher viel öfter noch mhm, mhm, mhm gesagt, damit die Gäste wissen, ich bin bei dir, mach weiter, alles super. Und jetzt kann ich mir das alles sparen. Es wird viel weniger gerummgehümmt in den Sendungen von mir, weil wir sehen uns. Und dann siehst du, der andere nickt, es gucken dich beide an. Manchmal wird auch gegrinst, wenn du einen Spruch machst. Und deswegen ist die Sendequalität insgesamt besser geworden durch diese Videoaufzeichnung. Da bin ich total happy drüber. Und ich bin auch so froh, dass es jetzt eine technische Möglichkeit gibt, die bezahlbar ist und das auch in einer halbwegs okayen Qualität, abhängig von der Webcam der Leute, dann bereitstellt.
Ich würde auch sagen, wenn wir uns da vor drei Jahren drüber unterhalten hätten, dann hätten wir beide wahrscheinlich gesagt, ne, ne, Video, das ist in keiner Weise möglich. Und wir haben uns schon drüber unterhalten und haben über Video für Tribünengespräche gesprochen und sämtliche Ideen, aber nie hätte man damals, wäre man damals davon ausgegangen, dass die Schlusskonferenzen, Analysesendungen, egal wie die herkömmlichen Formate, jetzt mit so einer Regelmäßigkeit als Video veröffentlicht werden. Und wenn man das gegenüberstellt, den Mehraufwand gegenüber dem Nutzen, den es hat, sowohl für die Zuseherinnen und den Zuseher als auch für die Gästinnen und Gäste, dann würde man wahrscheinlich im Nachhinein sagen, naja, auf jeden Fall macht man das. Es ist ein großer Mehraufwand. Max hat es eben beschrieben, Hardware ist mehr nötig. Natürlich kostet es mehr Zeit, aber durch die Tools, die wir haben, auch das Tool, mit dem wir hier aufnehmen, mit dem wir auch diese Sendung aufnehmen, wird es schon wahnsinnig vereinfacht und es ist wirklich toll, dass wir das jetzt so konstant machen können, auf jeden Fall.
Ich gewöhne mich sogar langsam daran, dass ich immer von so einer LED-Lampe angeleuchtet werde. Aber das ist das erste, was ich ausmache, wenn die Sendung vorbei ist. Auch nach dieser Sendung.
Jetzt haben wir auch nur noch einen kleinen Abschnitt vor uns. Ein paar private Fragen, eigentlich konkret zwei. Ich gehe mal mit der weniger privaten ran. RTL hat eine zweite Staffel von 11 Leben veröffentlicht. Und es gab die Frage, ob du da etwas zu sagen möchtest, ob du eine Meinung zu hast.
Ich schäme mich ein bisschen dafür, aber ich habe die immer noch nicht gehört. Und ich kann euch gar nicht sagen, warum. Also es ist jetzt nicht so, dass ich irgendwie was doof fände oder so, oder dass ich mich mit denen zerstritten hätte. Ich wollte erst warten, bis alle Folgen da sind, weil so mache ich es immer bei solchen Podcasts. Und dann habe ich aber andere serielle Formate nachgehört. Und es liegt immer noch in meiner Podcast-Queue. Deswegen kann ich inhaltlich nichts dazu sagen. Wir sind alle cool miteinander. Ich finde es schön, dass Elfleben weitergeht. Und wie sich das entwickelt, weiß ich ehrlich gesagt selber gar nicht. Deswegen kann ich da leider nicht so viel sagen. Aber es ist jetzt nicht so, dass es da Beef oder so gäbe. Und das haben ja auch manche Leute geschrieben. Warum ich das nicht empfehlen würde im Rasenfunk, das liegt auch nicht daran, dass ich irgendwie böse wäre, dass es da eine zweite Staffel gibt und ich bei der nicht beteiligt bin. Ich habe ja gesagt, ich möchte nicht beteiligt sein. Also das ist alles easy. Es ist halt grundsätzlich so, dass ich, wenn ich das nicht explizit sage, und das kommt vielleicht zweimal im Jahr vor, ich ausschließlich Sachen im Rasenfunk empfehle, die ich gehört habe. Weil ich das eben wichtig finde. Weil ich viele Podcast-Empfehlungen aus anderen Podcasts mitnehme und diesen Hosts vertraue. Und ich den Eindruck habe, so ist es am korrektesten. Und dadurch, dass ich F-Leben noch nicht gehört habe, konnte ich es bisher auch noch nicht empfehlen. Deswegen, ja. Aber ansonsten gibt es ja glaube ich nicht so viel zu sagen.
Vor allem, wenn man es nicht gehört hat.
Leider, es ist mir wirklich unangenehm. Es ist wirklich ein bisschen peinlich.
Die zweite Frage geht natürlich. Stammhörerinnen und Hörer wissen es. Du bist auf Wohnungssuche.
Ja, wenn es denn so wäre. Also, ihr habt ja alle den großen Ausschlag mitbekommen, weil er ja bis in den Rasenfunk hineinreichte mit nettevermietergesucht.de und ich habe mir vorher schon eine ganze Weile überlegt, will ich das wirklich machen? Weil a, trifft es ja viele Leute, die mir gar nicht helfen können und b, will man ja eigentlich diesen Privatkram gar nicht so sehr in den Rasenfunk reinholen. Ich hatte aber das Gefühl, es wäre nötig, diesen größtmöglichen Ausschlag zu machen. Und was soll ich sagen? Der Fakt, dass ich immer noch keine Wohnung gefunden habe, hat mich leider bestätigt. Es war leider wirklich nötig. Ich hatte natürlich noch andere Ausbaustufen. Das war nur eine von mehreren Dingen, die ich gemacht habe. Also hier auch Halb-Harlaching oder Ganz-Garlaching ist auch mit Zetteln von mir beklebt worden. Ich habe Anzeigen anderswo geschaltet und so weiter und so fort. Ihr müsst mir jetzt auch keine Tipps schicken, liebe Hörer. Das haben einige von euch gemacht. Das ist ganz lieb gemeint. Aber ich habe schon so auf dem Schirm, was man machen kann, um eine Wohnung zu finden. Aktuell gibt es da leider noch keine Neuigkeiten. Es war zwischendurch schwierig. Also es gab auch schon Absagen und so weiter. Es ist genauso schwierig, wie ich es mir vorgestellt habe, weil es eben ein Zimmer zu viel ist für München und ein Einkommen zu wenig. Also das vierte Zimmer und dass ich nur ein Einzelankommen bin, das ist das Problem. Und dann muss man auch sagen, das war zumindest bei einer Wohnung der Fall, die ich mir angeguckt habe, die tatsächlich rausgefallen ist, weil da hätte ich den Rasenfunk nicht produzieren können. Das wäre einfach aufgrund der baulichen Konstruktion nicht so gegangen, dass man das irgendwie, ja, wäre einfach nicht möglich gewesen. Und ein Büro anzumieten wäre A, teuer, und B, passt das eigentlich auch nicht in die Produktionsform des Rasenfunks rein, weil der kurze Weg vom Skyreceiver zum Rechner schon oft wichtig ist und auch der kurze Weg vom Rechner zum Bett, wenn ich dann mal wieder nachts die Frauensendung veröffentlicht habe. Also das gab es auch schon. Aber ja, also wenn ihr was wisst in München, sagt gerne Bescheid. Vielen Dank für die Mails, die ich gekriegt habe, die einfach nur lauteten, ich komme aus Hamburg, aber ich drücke dir die Daumen und grüße an den einen Nazi, der sich gemeldet hat. Du hast mich nicht damit ärgern können.
Sehr gut, ganz wichtig. Dann bleibt eigentlich nur noch die traditionelle Frage von Hermes Milner, Herr Oster, wie fühlen Sie sich?
Ich bin froh, dass wir häufig in der Zeit geblieben sind, weil ich weiß, Frank, dass es für dich jetzt auch gleich weitergeht. Deswegen fühle ich mich gut. Ich bin schon mittelerschöpft. Ich habe gerade noch Bauchkrummeln, was die EM angeht, weil ich das noch nicht organisiert bekommen habe. Und ich eigentlich das schon gerne vor zwei Wochen alles fertig gehabt hätte, aber das war aus ganz verschiedenen Gründen nicht möglich. Es ist schon sehr viel gerade. Der Royal war immer ein Brett, jetzt ist es ein komplett anderes Brett. Jetzt ist es so ein, als würde man sich in den Wüstensand reinstellen. Vorher war es so, dass es war, als würde man an einem Fließband arbeiten. Und dann am Schluss veröffentlicht man so etwas, macht aber die Tür zu und kann sich davon distanzieren. Jetzt ist es so, dass ich am Fließband arbeite und gleichzeitig um mich herum der Wüstensturm tobt mit dem Feedback zu allen möglichen Sendungen und mit Input zu laufenden Sendungen und so weiter. Das ist schon ein bisschen viel, aber das ist ja auch mein Problem und ich kann da ja auch einen Umgang mit finden. Ich glaube, den finde ich auch damit. Also grundsätzlich schon alles gut. Ich freue mich mega auf alles, was noch kommt. Ich glaube, es könnte ein ganz fantastisches Rasenfunk-Jahr werden. Ich finde es so schön, dass die Dinge, die wir uns überlegen, immer klappen. Wir haben noch nie eine Entscheidung getroffen, die wir zurückdrehen mussten. Da macht es sich bezahlt, dass wir immer lange drüber reden, dass wir uns Zeit lassen, dass wir noch nie was einfach so ganz spontan entschieden haben, ohne vorher schon mal drüber nachgedacht zu haben.
Ja oder zumindest, wenn es vielleicht auch nicht ideal läuft, könnte man den Shop vielleicht in die Kategorie nehmen, dass es aber dann auch kein wirklicher Fail ist, sondern dass wir dann einfach nach einer Zeit sagen, ok, das hat sich jetzt so nicht gelohnt, das lassen wir halt dann wieder bleiben. Und dann ist es auch gut. Mir geht es da genauso. Ich finde das auch gut. Da hat sich unsere Klausur im Idealfall zweimal pro Jahr auch bewährt, in der wir schon manche überraschendes Outcome hatten, das wir vorher selber nicht dachten, wo gar keine ganz großen Entscheidungen auf dem Tisch lagen und dann doch gefällt wurden. Da waren wir glaube ich auch schon das eine oder andere mal recht mutig. Und das finde ich auch ganz gut, dass wir das dann auch sein können und Dinge verändern können. Und ich glaube, wir sind an einigen Dingen, das Intro mag ich da mal erwähnen. Du hast es ja heute schon erwähnt, an einigen Dingen hing dann auch das Herzblut so ein bisschen. Und da Veränderungen vorzunehmen, ist immer besonders schwierig. Aber das muss dann halt manchmal trotzdem sein. Und genauso die Namen der Feeds, die Schlusskonferenz war eigentlich unvorstellbar, dass dieser Name wegfällt. Und aus heutiger Sicht sagt man, naja, so what? Das hat jetzt halt passiert und geht weiter.
Ja, ja, ist ein guter Aspekt. Und gleichzeitig muss man auch dazu sagen, dass wir gesegnet sind mit einer sehr verständnisvollen Community. Also ich finde, das muss man so lobhudeleimäßig sich das jetzt anhört. Aber wir wissen auch, dass wir euch im Grunde eigentlich alles zumuten können. Wir könnten uns jetzt sogar umbenennen und nicht mehr Rasenfunk heißen. Dann fändet ihr das alles traurig. Aber wenn wir das einmal erklären in der Sendung, warum wir es gemacht haben, dann geht ihr das alles mit. Und es gibt ganz selten Misstrauen uns gegenüber. Wir waren sogar richtig davon überrascht, als das mal der Fall war, als wir GmbH werden wollten. Da hat uns doch irgendjemand Steuervermeidung oder irgendwie so vorgeworfen. Und das war so unüblich für die Rasenfunk-Community, dass uns das richtig überrascht hat. Neben dem Effekt, dass das leider tatsächlich im Gegenteil der Fall ist bei der GmbH. Aber das ist wirklich ein großes Privileg. Und das einzige, was tatsächlich schade ist, ist, wir haben jetzt einen zehnten Geburtstag vor uns. Viele andere befreundete Podcasts haben den auch. Der Milan Ton ist jetzt zehn Jahre alt geworden. Der Vertical Pass wird jetzt zehn Jahre alt. Radio Nucular wird jetzt zehn Jahre alt. Total interessant. Der reingemachte Podcast ist jetzt wieder da. Nach gefühlt zehn Jahren Pause. Das ist das einzige, was so ein bisschen schade ist. Da werden wir es, glaube ich, nicht schaffen, irgendwas Großes zu machen oder so. Das ist einfach nicht drin. Dafür liegt der zehnte Geburtstag zu doof. Dafür ist dieses Jahr zu anstrengend. Mit zu vielen Umschwingen. Aber vielleicht feuern wir dann den elften Geburtstag. Das würde ja auch zum Rasenfunk passen, irgendwie. Aber Frank, wie geht es denn dir?
Haha, gut eigentlich. Ganz gut. Ich kann nicht klagen. Ich finde, was den Rasenfunk angeht, für mich sehr schade, dass ich mich über die Jahre so weit vom Fußball entfernt habe. Aber ich habe es mehrfach probiert. Daran lässt sich nicht wirklich was drehen. Das hatte jetzt die Konsequenz von einem halben oder dreiviertel Jahr, dass ich auch sämtliche Abos dahingehend beendet habe, weil ich habe es schlicht nicht mehr genutzt. Es war einfach wirklich das letzte Jahr schon ziemlicher Blödsinn dafür noch zu zahlen. Der Rasenfunk ist jetzt meine einzige Verbindung zum Fußball, sozusagen neben Deutschlandfunk Sport, jeden Morgen vor den Nachrichten die vier Minuten. Das ist immer noch ein bisschen schade. Dem traue ich ein bisschen nach. Aber das ist halt so ein Trauern, weil ich gerne näher dran wäre. Aber ich merke, dass mir einfach völlig das Interesse fehlt dafür. Und es kommt nicht wieder. Ich habe eigentlich gedacht, ich brauche mal so eine Jahrpause. Dann kommt es schon wieder. Ich kriege natürlich irgendwie alles Wichtige mit. Der Rasenfunk ist dafür ideal. Ich freue mich auch dafür, die Bestätigung zu bekommen, dass das, was wir machen, funktioniert. Aber ich muss halt immer mehr sagen, das, was du machst in erster Linie. Du hast es vorhin angeschnitten, dass irgendwann mal geplant war, dass wir zusammen moderieren. Aus anderen Gründen ist es dazu nicht gekommen. Aber dass ich mittlerweile inhaltlich so weit davon weg bin, ärgert mich ein bisschen, wenn man das so sagen kann.
Aber es liegt am Geschäft, es liegt nicht an dir, Frank. So deutlich, wie du es tatsächlich sagen willst. Ja, aber ich habe mir das auch gedacht. Ich habe den FC Bayern-Part, weiß gerade nicht, also er wird ziemlich sicher nach diesem Tribünengespräch erst erscheinen. Den habe ich gestern Abend aufgenommen mit Stefan Meyer, den kennst du ja auch gut. Und das war im Grunde ein Gespräch, bei dem zufällig noch das Band lief. Also ganz andere Struktur als all die anderen Royalfolgen. Ich habe mich aber so wohl gefühlt, dass ich das einfach ablaufen lassen. Und danach habe ich mir original gedacht, krass, solche Gespräche hatten wir früher auch, wir zwei. Früher war es manchmal noch so, dass wir wegen Rasenfunk einen Call gemacht haben und dann haben wir über irgendwelche Bayern-Trainer gesprochen und so weiter. Und das ist jetzt leider gar nicht mehr so. Aber so ist es halt.
So verändern sich die Dinge. Aber nichtsdestotrotz, nur um das auch klarzustellen, habe ich natürlich zum Rasenfunk selber die engste Verbindung und den größten Spaß daran, diese Dinge rund um den Fußball, was beim Rasenfunk passiert, mitzuentscheiden, mitzuentwickeln, mitzudenken. Aber es ist halt immer weniger aus einem Fußball-Fan-Bezug. Und natürlich war es bei mir sowieso nie der ernsthaft journalistische Bezug. Der Blick dafür ist natürlich da, dadurch, dass wir uns ja viel darüber unterhalten, was man eben journalistisch machen kann im Rasenfunk. Aber der Fan-Bezug oder der leidenschaftliche Fußball-Bezug ist halt leider einfach weg. Aber so entwickeln sich die Dinge.
So entwickeln sich die Dinge. Wir haben zum Glück noch andere Themen, über die wir miteinander sprechen können.
Mehr als genug.
Nicht nur.
Den Rasenfunk. Frank, ich glaube, wir sind durch, oder? Ich weiß nicht.
Das Dokument ist am Ende und wir sind es nicht.
Gott sei Dank, aber …Ja, aber was wir noch tun müssen, ist, wir wollen auch an dieser Stelle natürlich ein paar SupporterInnen danken. Da kannst du sehr gerne mal in den Signal-Chat von uns beiden schauen. Dann würde ich doch sagen, da mache ich die ersten. Und danke ihnen. Und dann kannst du die weiteren dann nehmen. Ich bedanke mich herzlich bei Atta, bei Birneweich, bei Björn und beim Ruhrpott-Frosch.
Und außerdem bedanken wir uns bei Thomas, der Stehplatz-Helden, Jan-Philipp, Oliver B.,
Vielen herzlichen Dank. Auf rasenfunk.de/supporterscluberfahrtihr, wie man uns unterfahren kann, äh, unterstützen kann. Auf kiosks.rasenfunk.de könnt ihr uns bitte, bitte tassen und die letzten Hoodies und so weiter abkaufen und abonniert sehr gerne den Rasenfunk Nationalteams-Video. Da gibt es dann alles zu EM. In diesem Sinne, danke dir, Frank.
Danke, Max.
Macht's gut, ihr alle. Bleibt gesund.
Bis bald, ciao ciao.
Wir geben nun zurück in die angeschlossenen Funkhäuser. Für heute.